A Twitter campaign for me guys.
Brian,
mother flogging Callan.
You can find him on Twitter at br.
Why?
I'm sure someone is,
someone has confiscated B R I a n count.
How dare they and they probably fucked you probably done terrible things to that
account.
I hate the name Brian Cause I have to.
I say it's Broy.
Oh,
it wasn't knowing.
You know,
it's a unique great.
So I spent my whole life going next.
Actually it with a y.
It's a boring name to begin with.
It's not like it's a unique name dude.
I'm Joe.
That is the most that is.
Yeah,
but you can't really mess with that name.
Jail.
It's just so simple.
I've seen people write ready j o on line at Starbucks.
They're trying to fuck with me.
They're trying to make me a woman.
I know you have a lot of feminine energy.
Honestly,
I didn't want to go.
I'm Jay.
Oh yeah,
we the features.
You're your delicate features in your face that long actual,
I knows I've delicate bones.
Joe.
Is that a girl or a boy?
That Guy Rolling J.
Oh,
Rogan's girl.
Mm.
This is how unoriginal my family is.
My grandmother's name was Josephine.
My grandfather's name was Joseph.
How?
My Dad's name was Joseph and my name is Joseph.
Terrible fucking apes.
Don't fucking cage my ne.
My grandma's name is rose [inaudible] name is Dominic stills a normal limb.
Korea.
Michael.
Yeah.
My mother had a cool name,
but she didn't like it.
My mother was born and it was a Santa I Santa Santa's Dan.
She didn't like it.
She hated it.
She changed it to Susan.
That's crazy.
Yeah,
she would,
she wouldn't let anybody,
I didn't even know her name was a Sante until I was like in high school.
My friends,
his mother was a hippie and she named him Blue Quan one Tega.
Oh,
no.
Lawless.
No.
It's like I didn't like Gwyneth Paltrow namer kid apple buy without even knowing
that.
I will say say to you 100% she did,
but it's like,
you know there's,
we have an issue with that,
but what,
you know,
why is apple any worse than Joe?
It's not.
It's just not.
I think that people have,
I have,
and I don't even know how to explain it and I,
and I'm going to get into a larger point about it.
I had this strange reaction and it's not a positive one.
Whenever a celebrity in Hollywood names their kids something really cool,
right?
Like it might be adorable if it was your neighbor,
yeah.
Of Your name or had a kid named apple and they were really nice.
I think what makes me more,
what annoys me more is that they're making the name of the kid about themselves,
not about the kid.
Oh,
I see what you're saying.
That's what bothers me about it.
Yeah.
I think you're probably onto something good.
You're onto you.
You sense the pretension?
Yeah.
Like when when puffy combs,
I think it was word,
it's pretension,
but it's also a little bit of spectacle.
It's a little bit and like,
Hey,
I named my kid Brooklyn,
apple and a rumor,
which are all cool names and I'm not saying,
and maybe I would do the same,
but I do feel like the,
again,
of course you're making a little bit about yourself.
You've got to name your kid,
maybe you feel the pressure to name your kid.
Something very different.
I Dunno.
Yeah,
I think I'm being a little,
no,
you're wrong.
You're onto something though.
We don't like like fake energy people.
Nobody likes like I'm a healer.
You know what I mean?
Is like that fakeness that comes with.
But we do like,
like we were talking about yoga before this show started.
Like we like people that are really in the yoga because they actually enjoy the
benefits of it.
And then really they're really kind of down to earth and centered.
Those are nice people to be around.
Yes.
But the ones who were faking that thing are fucking gross.
So they're wearing it like a costume.
Right?
So it becomes a character that they've taken over.
And again,
that's something called affectation.
They're not doing it for the utility of Yoga,
like where you're working something out,
whether it's peace of mind or getting more centered or whatever,
uh,
and getting healthier.
I think that some people actually wear that cloak and become somewhat tyrannical
about it.
They put on the outfit,
the costume.
Now there are Yogi.
Now they're going to speak about being on the spiritual path and within that is
always a little bit of a look at this,
these common cattle,
these people who drink coffee and other stimulants and obviously eat meat.
You know,
that's kind of what I think we react to.
Oh,
I was listening to this conversation and yoga class with this woman who was
advising this man on what he should do with his diet,
and she was saying that meat is toxic.
It's toxic,
it's toxic going.
I mean,
the way she was doing,
I was like,
what do you see?
It's fucking protein and water.
Like it's one of the most easily digestible things that people eat that good.
What I love to do with people like that,
whenever they mentioned toxins,
like you sweat out all these toxins.
I go,
dude,
what title would explore?
What are the toxins going through your sweat?
Yeah.
What are they,
you know,
were toxins gets filtered.
Your fucking little liver.
Okay.
Yeah,
and your kids are in your blood.
Your liver filters it out.
You're not getting toxins out of your body,
right?
Oh,
somebody told me they did some foot thing where they put you in a foot bath and
then it turns brown.
Yeah,
because the toxins in your body,
while they've done experiments on that,
which is it,
it reacts with the metal in the water to create with the sodium,
a certain sodium compound and it creates rust.
It's rust.
Oh,
so what is it they're putting on your feet?
They put like put your feet in there.
Yeah,
they put your feet in there and then they have a,
an electric charge or put potassium in it like a,
a nail with an electric charge.
Toxins,
man.
And that Brown stuff is coming out of your feet and make a lot of money.
That's why he tried to tell me that like take,
they're taking the toxins out of your body and after you do it,
you just feel amazing.
It's like,
Oh God,
this is one of the beautiful things about the Internet is those people like you
can go,
okay,
is that real?
And then you Google it and you'd go,
no,
here's all these studies.
And they show that you're retarded.
There's a book I read about that where they,
they break that particular thing down that that,
that for putting your feet in the water turns brown and all the toxins come out.
God,
it's so dumb,
but it's like here it is before iron after 30 minute treatment.
Amazing.
Except for you.
They're the same thing.
And take your feet out and put another compound in there.
It turns Brown as well.
Look at that fucking bullshit.
Look at that like they're,
they're really trying to pretend that all that Brown is coming out of your body.
If you have all that stuff in your body,
you fucking dying.
All right.
That's really bad.
Yeah,
it's very weird of sucks it out of your body.
So gross.
There's so much that gross fake shit out there that gross fake like healing and
psychic healers in zone healers,
even that,
even that is always,
if you actually scratch into it.
And I spent a nut,
you know me,
I got a lot of patients from those people that do love him.
And,
and how about the one who came up to you the other day?
The one that we both know that,
uh,
said do something.
It's about allowing,
oh,
please tell me more.
Please tell me more about this text message.
We don't have to name him.
He said,
please tell me more.
It's just an interesting,
I,
I'm very hesitant to,
in case he listens to the or that person listens to your podcasts and everything
else to us.
But yeah,
some people tend to decide that they,
I think it's very common,
especially in La,
in places for people to believe that they have found the answer.
I know all this conventional wisdom is,
um,
is is your thing.
But I actually have a roundabout way and then they'll play with words and I'll
say it's not about doing,
it's kind of about allowing,
like I,
and I,
you know,
I love that.
I'm just like,
I'll give you roll probably like,
dude,
that's amazing.
Tell me more immediately so I can talk about it on Joe Rogan's podcast with 16
million.
Oh Christ.
You deal with that all the time,
man.
You,
you,
I think my,
my biggest thing with the healer kind of crowd,
and some of them are great people of course,
and maybe they do some good of course,
but a lot of them are wearing it at to bludgeon you with it or it's a piece of
identity.
It's,
it's,
everything else has kind of gone.
I got unwell and they turn their own crisis into sort of a,
you know,
they've,
they've found their calling,
which is a healer.
You also,
I don't buy a,
don't buy the ideas of people that are like trying to be leaders are trying to
push things and trying to like create these movements and trying to,
if they don't do something to push themselves.
Like if I see you and you have a sloppy face and a big old double chin and your
gut is hanging off your pants,
your greedily await your food.
As you're sitting around with all these people that are listening to you,
I'm like,
you're a guy that's caught up in the grips of not taking care of your own meat
wagon.
Yeah.
So why am I gonna listen to you?
About how you describe how we're supposed to live life and how the peaceful
energy flows through your shock rose and like,
what do you,
what do you what?
What exactly are you saying?
You just trying to get people to listen to because that's what it kind of seems
like.
Well,
it kind of seems like you just want to be a leader that's,
that's usually what it is.
They don't,
yeah.
They don't push themselves.
Yeah.
I think unless you're involved in some adverse situation,
some situation where you have to encounter adversity and find out what you're
made of,
whatever you're doing,
whenever pursuit,
if you do in one of those,
what else?
Crazy mudders,
those crazy,
racist,
tough mudder.
Tough mudders.
People love that man.
You know why they love that?
Because they are getting fucking pushed.
They have to find out what they're made out of.
You don't find that in a cubicle.
You just fucking don't.
Right.
I think there's a crazy desire that people have to do triathlons.
I'm gonna see if I can do it.
I want to do a sub three hour marathon.
It was like these fucking desires to push yourself because we don't encounter
enough mortality.
We don't encounter enough disease.
We don't encounter enough sadness to make ourselves aware of the special moment
that you have when you've achieved peace.
And I really think we have a genetic memory of all those things.
I do.
You know,
you're putting in a world where you're don't,
you're not being tested.
I struggle is such a huge part of the human experience and needs and are they
other thing about Gulu is though,
is that when you see somebody who talks a lot and they're telling you the
secrets and methodology and technology of life,
the problem with that is that when you see below really accomplished something
like John Wayne par or whatever,
if you guys tell him we par to tell me the secrets of fighting John Wayne,
Paul would look at me and go,
oh well you'd probably have to go train for 10 years.
And a lot of it is something you'd have to experience and practice.
Not something I can tell you about.
And I think anybody who has these,
uh,
sharp profile who has really,
really cool ways of putting words together,
you shouldn't be a little aware,
be aware,
be a little bit of where it's a good example that you are what I would consider
a master standup comedian.
You've been doing standup comedy for more than a decade professionally.
You're hilarious.
You know,
every time I see you,
you're killing.
If you had to tell someone how to do stand up,
how would,
how the fuck would you even begin?
And imagine having the gall to tell someone how they should do stand.
It's incredible.
But the reality is life is kind of like stand up in a way in that you have to do
it your way.
You know?
And if you like wearing dresses and ball gags and getting beat up,
I checked who fucking mice had is something wrong with that?
As long as you're not hurting anybody and if you are hurting them is because
they want you to hurt them.
You're in some weird situation.
W who gives a fuck really?
Who gives a fuck?
It's so when some guy comes along,
it's not,
it's about allowing sometimes,
sometimes about being beating your car going fuck you.
Fuck you,
fuck you.
And then you go to work with a big smile on your face.
Yeah.
Cause you were laughing in the,
and jokingly completely in the nature of like joking around all through your day
or were for Shit,
mouth and people fuck mouth the people.
I do that all the time.
It's therapeutic.
I do it all the time just for amusement.
I amuse myself,
right.
I like,
I'll see myself in the car like come on,
fuck face,
come on,
fuck face you could to you fucking dummy.
You're fucking dummy.
I'm never really mad at that guy.
I'm a mocking it cause it's fun to do it.
It makes an a normal,
ordinary moment entertaining.
Right.
So I think you're right.
I think it is.
I think life is a lot like stand up in that sense.
You know,
we have different styles of living.
it's,
it's one of the cool things about life and I think everybody's person,
like different personalities gravitate towards different styles of living just
automatically and organically.
The,
some way people gravitate towards jobs,
you know,
the way some people are just drawn,
I want to be a comic book illustrator.
I'm drawn to it,
you know,
or some people are fucking,
I've always loved music,
man.
Just always wanted to be a musician.
There's even that,
my son,
I told you I went to,
I watched him at his school play whatever and he's not even four.
And,
and it was so funny because all the kids were singing their songs and doing
their thing and my son is on the sidelines pulling his mouth open as wide as he
possibly can,
can then he'd shops over and just jumps in this kid's face.
Then he decides I'm getting Outta here,
pulls his shirt up and walks off stage.
He gets the teacher's chasing him,
he realizes it,
he's disrupting everything.
And he did a variation of that for all four songs.
And my wife was like,
you know,
this is crazy and this is bad.
And I,
and I,
I was like,
listen,
all I know is I was exactly the same.
I don't remember it being a good thing.
It's probably going to be a bit of a struggle for him.
Who knows how to navigate it.
But there's one thing for sure,
he's not a conformist.
He's very different and he sees the world very differently and he'd way rather
be doing this thing over here.
And you know,
I kind of looked,
I was like,
I thought to myself,
I've always been the exact same way.
I've always been that way.
I've always wondered if it's a genetics I,
it has to be because he's so similar to me,
to the point where I remember doing that.
I remember going,
this is embarrassing,
I'm not going to sing like everybody else.
I remember looking over,
I was in kindergarten and I saw their mouths wide open and they were singing.
And I was like,
well,
that's embarrassing.
And My mother came over and she said,
what?
What's wrong?
And I said,
I don't think we should be doing this.
And she said,
why?
And I said,
because we're not that good.
I knew at that age,
I was very aware at that age how bad we were at singing and dancing.
You know,
it's fun.
And I think my son felt the same way.
He was a little embarrassed at the bad performance because there's nothing worse
than seeing,
I dunno,
16,
three and a half year olds trying to sing a song.
Yeah.
You got to wait until they're five before you even go to those things.
For Real.
They just hundred percent.
I just can't do it yet.
Forget it.
It's chaos.
But it's adorable.
People love watching their kids do things,
you know?
It's like their kid gets to be a star for a brief moment in time.
It's true.
Yeah.
That's a weird thing.
It's a weird thing.
What is your,
let me ask you this question.
We haven't talked about it,
but,
and be honest.
What was the,
we are first reaction,
like your first gut reaction if you even had one when you
saw,
um,
the picture of Bruce Jenner on Vanity Fair under the title.
Call me Caitlyn.
Well,
I got it when I was bear hunting with a bow and arrow.
Let's just pause for a second.
That's when I got it.
Let's have a moment of silence for that.
Jamie sent it to me.
Jamie was the first one to send it to me and then my wife sent it to me and I
was like,
oh fuck.
Actually know my wife was first and Jamie was second.
Sorry Dude.
She got,
yeah,
but it was very close.
It was basically both of them send it to me.
Um,
and uh,
I had bear blood on my clothes and uh,
we were stopping into this town to go on a doc to catch some Walleye in northern
pike and as dark as it gets.
Yeah.
I was doing man shit.
For real man.
Shit.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean,
um,
eat meat or don't eat meat,
but if you are going to eat meat,
you really can't be upset at people hunting.
You really can't because it's exciting and uh,
it takes,
it's a huge discipline and the food is amazing.
The meat that you get from wild game is so much better.
It also the money that p that parks make from hunting and and on wildlife
federation fishing wildlife preserve a great deal of habitat for animals.
It's what it preserves more habitat for animals because of hunting than anything
else.
The conservation aspect of hunting is totally overlooked because people want to
look at hunters like there's some evil person the kid would just with living in
this really fucked up,
contradictory society where every day you're driving on the street,
you're passing by gas stations that are filled with meat,
snacks,
disgusting meat that's ground up into some fucking goofy hamburger and frozen
and you microwave it.
All these,
all that shit.
Those been in beef burritos.
They sell.
What is that?
That's murdered animals that were ground up and they come from three different
countries sometimes that were killed six months ago.
Oh,
easily.
Easily.
Who knows how long that she has been frozen for and the,
nobody seems to,
it's doesn't seem to phase anyone.
You know,
you walk into a supermarket,
you're passing by just rows and rows of meet you.
Every Mcdonald's,
every Jack in the box is meat,
meat,
meat.
But we're,
we're completely disconnected from it by living in this.
I think cities are awesome by the way.
And you know,
one,
I really started to appreciate cities when you and I started going on these
trips.
Yeah,
well it's when you and I went to Montana,
or even better recently,
like it's perfect example when we did that Prince of Wales show,
we went on to Prince of Wales Island.
We got rained on every fucking day for five days and when we came back to la,
it was amazing.
I loved this place so much.
The son felt so good because one of the greatest message I've ever gotten from
me,
I just get this random message a,
hey,
it's Joe.
Um,
hey,
do you feel really great?
I feel fucking amazing.
I don't know if you do,
but I feel fucking amazing man.
How do you feel?
Do you feel amazing?
Like don't fucking know what he's talking about.
Like I was on drugs,
like coming back from that rainy,
miserable cold five days to come back to la.
Felt like I was on drugs.
It was because I realized that like we had a,
first of all,
we had a great time being rainy and miserable,
laughing our asses off.
It was moving when I saw Steve [inaudible] at the end of that say,
you know,
I kind of Ms. Bryan and Joe's comedy because being up here alone,
there's a profound sadness.
I feel.
I feel that way too.
Actually.
Did you feel that?
Like very sad.
I feel so sad when I look out.
I have,
maybe I feel so alone or I feel like,
um,
what it was would be like to live in such solitude in such silence was time.
Totally humbling.
It's totally humbling.
And I feel like I might be totally bullshitting here.
Okay.
And I'm going to,
we'll new admit that.
But I feel like when,
even if I'm in a beautiful park,
like setting,
like if you go to Griffith Park and you're sitting up in there,
even if you find yourself a swath of land where all you see is trees and you're
sitting down,
there's still,
there's a feeling in the air of civilization and the feeling of the air of
civilization.
I don't know if it's Wifi signals or radio signals,
a television signals or cellular signals.
I don't,
and I don't know if it's an actual physical thing.
I don't know if there's a feeling that you get,
obviously you can't tune in to someone's cell phone with your fucking brain,
but are you aware in some sort of weird peripheral sense that all these signals
are around you all the time?
I don't know,
but I know that it feels totally different to be outside on a mountain in Prince
of Wales.
There's a feeling in the air and there's this,
this first of all,
this very humbling,
absolute,
undeniable realization that not only are you not special,
but that this part of the world does not give a fuck about that.
So I was going to say,
and we'll forget about you,
the moment you stop existing,
you're so insignificant,
so in you're so insignificant and I think a lot of my sadness came from feeling
like being on par with a tree next to me.
I'm that anonymous on that insignificant and there's nothing around here that
cares about me.
Maybe that's an egocentric way to look at it,
but it certainly was very real and felt that way.
Um,
and I just,
I don't know.
Uh,
it's,
um,
I think it was supposed to experience that.
I think it keeps people in line.
I think there's two things that we fucked up on as a,
as a,
as a race.
Um,
well many things obviously,
but two things that we fucked up on the are rarely discussed.
And I think one of them is that we have almost a built in need to be around
nature.
And when you're around nature,
you get feelings from that,
from that experience that are not,
they're not described enough.
They're not expanded upon enough.
They're not endorsed and,
and appreciate it enough.
I think it's an integral part of being a person.
And I think that when we're spending all of our times in these hard surfaces and
the straight lines and these things that we create,
I just do not think it's good for you.
I think it's your body's not designed for it.
And I think there's some reward systems that you get from being out in,
in these solitary environments.
It's certainly what most of our history is.
Very little stimulus.
If you think about the amount of stimulus,
auditory and visual stimulus you deal with every day from just blinking lights,
uh,
all the things you see,
our very recent ancestors were not ever exposed to that.
They say sometimes that we're exposed to more seamless than a day than some of
our ancestors where their whole life in,
in terms of how predictable,
still a expansive their lives were.
Where you didn't venture,
you couldn't venture too far.
You know,
the other thing about where we were,
especially in Prince of Wales island was that not even native Americans would go
up there.
In fact,
even animals would be like,
you know what?
Too rainy up here.
We're going to go down below.
So we were kind of truly where no one in their right mind would Canelo he's
fucking maniac the mountain goat.
He's a fucking maniac.
That look legit maniac,
a long suffering mountain waiting to get Claudia grizzly.
The,
I remember there was one of the first things he told me,
I get clawed like right across the chest,
like right chair and was like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Man,
if that happens,
you're most likely dead.
He's amazing.
Yeah.
I wonder if he feels differently now that he got run over by a moose.
Did you ever see that episode moves?
Got Him fucked.
Moose charged him and got behind him and fucking nailed him in the ass.
They're not friendly animals to Hillary shot it.
It was already shot at.
Yeah,
it was down and wounded and he walked up on a wounded Moose and it ran at him
and his gun.
Misfired wow,
dude.
Yeah,
Dude.
I mean that's death.
I mean,
you could really easily get stomped to death.
Yeah.
If I,
if I had it watch just watching the video,
I did not have a sense of how truly big they are when you see one in real life.
I have,
and I had not seen what,
I don't think I had seen one before a hunted them.
Uh,
maybe I,
oh no,
I have for sure your care.
I have for sure because I was with Ari and we took pictures of him in Alaska,
but it was females.
I hadn't seen one with the full antlers before.
It was in the summer and it was females.
Um,
and they were really,
really,
really big.
But the ones that we saw when we were in BC like fucking Christ,
just think about shooting that thing and this is work Rinella was in BC to
shooting that thing that it stomps you.
Yeah,
no thanks.
Fuck man.
That starts so goddamn big.
Yeah.
The one I got was 900 pounds.
The one my friend Ben O'brian got was 1400 pounds,
1400 pound,
1400 pounds I think.
I think a horse,
the average horse ways like 1,102,
it was so big.
She walked out into the road in front of us and the charge that you get,
the adrenaline charge,
when you see one,
you're like cheese us.
They didn't even look real.
They were both the same size.
They're both these enormous bachelor's.
It was right after they had got done running and say they were just eating like
crazy.
There were starved because they've been fucking for weeks and weeks and weeks
and they walked out into the middle of the road and we slammed the brakes in the
car and you look at them like their body was bigger than the top of the tree.
It was like up to like the windshield area of the trustees.
They're insane how big they are by the way.
He,
we were talking about your first reaction to Caitlyn Jenner.
Yeah,
no,
I'm going to get back to,
Oh,
you are?
Yeah.
The other thing that I was going to say is I think we are,
and I want this to be like,
I'm trying to be as objective about this as possible and I'm trying to be as
sensitive about this as possible,
but I think,
I think all this move towards the feminine and demonizing masculine behavior and
all of this,
um,
uh,
appreciation for marginalized people is all,
it's all awesome.
I really think it's important.
I think people go too crazy with it and they attack people that would ordinarily
be their allies.
But I think that would all this is doing like the reason why this move towards
acceptance is,
is happening.
It's because I think we're evolving and I think that as people are evolving and
as we realized that there really is no right or wrong way to live.
And if Bruce Jenner wants to be a woman now who gives a fuck,
he should totally be a woman.
I think this is,
this is all a positive thing and it's all moving towards some softer style of
being a human being.
And um,
it probably won't be within our lifetime,
but I think several lifetimes from now,
people are probably going to be way kinder on a regular basis than they are
right now.
I think they're way kinder today than they've ever been before.
Way more aware of things now than they've ever been for me to empathize because
we have too much information to know how similar we are to say a white guy as to
a Chinese person,
to a black person.
And it's just right.
It's hard to deny that.
You rarely see somebody arguing that.
And this is where I think the divide comes in.
There's a,
there's an anti masculinity fee feeling and like that,
you know,
men who are into things are jocks and meatheads and assholes.
And if you're into sports or martial arts or other,
that somehow or another,
because you embrace this,
it excites you and you enjoy it and you are surround yourself with other people
that also enjoy it.
There must be something wrong with you.
You must be a mean person.
Like just because you're masculine,
you must be mean.
I reject that outright.
I think it's ridiculous that also you must be insensitive and cruel.
I reject that as well outright.
It's not true.
You can be masculine,
obese,
very sensitive.
Did I had to do this fucking thing for the UFC yesterday where it was a speech
about the hall of fame and Jeff Blatnick is,
uh,
getting into the hall of fame and Jeff Blatnick,
who's an Olympic gold medalist,
Greco Alexander,
Carolyn and uh,
and Greco Roman,
who's a,
this amazing guy.
And um,
I started crying.
I was like,
I had to stop myself from crying when I was talking about this guy because he
beat cancer and won a gold medal.
And then he was like really nice to me,
man.
Like when I first started wearing big Jeff,
who's a great guy and so I'm a bitch dude.
I cry all the time.
I cried.
I'm,
I'm emotional like about a lot of shit all the time,
man.
A movie or even some songs will get me,
I'll be in my car and a song or make me fucking crying.
It doesn't mean because someone embraces masculine activities,
whether it's martial arts or whether it's,
um,
hunting or anything,
it doesn't mean that that person's going to be homophobic.
It doesn't mean that that person is going to be a negative person or,
but there's this push,
I think because of what's happening now with,
um,
with all this,
our society's movement towards civilization and movement towards a much more
nonviolent life,
although the awareness of rape man.
But there hadn't been a lot of rape going on in college when I was young,
but I never fucking heard about it.
But all you're hearing about it like on a constant basis is the amount of sexual
violence that takes place in colleges.
And some people are saying they're overreacting to this,
that,
but it's good.
Like it's all this trend of like revving the voices.
The was the voice.
Yes.
And recognizing that,
what is important here?
Is it the style of life?
Is it the style of life you live?
Is it a buy?
Should I be mad at you if you wear a dress?
No.
Why?
She'd be mad at you if you rape people that were dresses.
I should be mad at you if you beat people up because you don't like the way they
look like Twitter today.
Some trans woman had a black eye.
Uh,
and there was some,
you know,
she made some tweet about it.
I forget her name.
I don't,
I don't know.
I don't follow her.
I just,
I clicked on a link and I found it and it was some guy punched her for being a
transgender person.
Just fun.
And Kristen Beck was on her podcast and talk.
I'm,
I'm flattering kid and talked about getting beat up chest because she walked by
some guys,
seal team six commando and they had heard it from behind,
but that,
that,
that's an everyday reality and every day,
very,
very short time ago,
and I'm talking about less than 15 years ago and our lifetime,
any of those derogatory words like Fag Faggot,
making fun of gay people was an acceptable prejudice.
Oh,
you've heard it all the time.
All of us said it because you just made fun of people.
Well,
how bout like you go listen to like some old Eddie Murphy listen to behind raw.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
Meanwhile it's like really like hate speech.
Yeah.
Meanwhile he likes it was allegedly,
allegedly.
Yeah.
Well,
you know what they say?
you know when you're talking about also is like Matthew Arnold who was this
awesome sort of philosopher romantic and he said,
yes,
the United States is the,
and forgive me if it's not Matthew,
I'm almost positive it is,
is.
Yes.
The United States is a very powerful country with the biggest guns in a roaring
stock market.
And the national football league.
But somewhere along the line,
if you embrace all of that,
you'll forget to be interesting.
And you have to remember as a country,
as a society,
that you must make place for the gentler spirits for your artists,
for your quote Unquote Weirdos for dreamers,
for your wonders.
And,
and I,
I think that's,
to our credit that,
that,
you know,
it does create more beauty.
It does create a more diversity of,
creates more interesting innovation when people who don't have the biggest
muscles feel safe,
feel like they have a voice,
feel like they have somewhere to go.
If they get beat up.
You have a society where muscles and guns,
I,
he,
Rome,
I,
he,
Russia,
yeah,
we're muscles and ground guns ruled the roost.
And that most of the world,
by the way,
when all these guys that are getting beaten up in Russia for being gay,
it's like a really common she,
exactly.
So anytime you,
most societies concern themselves almost exclusively with how to control their
populations,
whether they do it through sheer force like Russia does or whether they do it
through,
um,
religion like Saudi Arabia.
Does those countries essentially practice a form of apartheid?
And what I mean by that is at 50% of their population,
at least to say nothing of the gay people and the different people in the
transgender people,
those people are so marginalized and they're wasted because they're put in one
place and they're told to do just a couple of things that have been allowed by
this male,
um,
architecture.
This male scaffolding has been put in place and been there forever.
And it just stifles spirit.
It stifles ingenuity,
creativity,
and most of all,
it stifles the truth.
And in that sense,
you know,
of course there's a place for these people in these societies have evolved.
And there's a lot of great things about Russian society and Saudi society and
everything else.
But that's an important aspect to keep in mind.
That's,
that's an important thing.
And that's what I think this movement is a positive thing.
Well,
it's about information.
You know,
these people have a voice now and you start thinking of them as people as
opposed to like,
like transgender people never had a community before that.
I mean what,
how would they would have to find other transgender people and hang out with
them.
It would be very difficult to get that going.
Now you meet online,
you have these forums,
have Twitter and things along those lines.
Like well that's from any weird generally marginalized parts of society can find
a community.
Now did you and Nick Swardson this choker?
I believe it's on a specialist,
so I'm not,
I don't get that.
He goes for the Internet.
If you had a fetish,
it kinda sucked because you kind of had to kind of try it out on the person.
You'd be at dinner and you'd be like,
all right,
I'm going to go to the bathroom.
Torque.
It was joke on the air.
I think he's already done this.
Yeah,
I wouldn't know otherwise.
But he goes,
well I'm gonna go to the bathroom or it could piss on your face just getting,
just getting any luck.
It's like,
it's so fucking true.
That's so true.
You have find it.
But my,
my feeling with the Caitlyn Jenner thing,
it was only that,
um,
I kind of felt like there are two things that go on in my mind now.
This one is that I found that he was,
she was now it looked like I have a bit of 35,
not 65.
That was good.
Photoshop.
Well,
you know,
the other thing is he underwent a 12 hour surgery to more feminized his face.
Apparently up until now.
He preferred the feet,
the he pronoun.
I don't,
I don't know if he's saying she know.
I believe she is.
It's Miss Jenner if you don't mind.
She,
yeah.
So what you're saying,
I'm saying she,
and again and again I am by the way,
your,
your face and your tone.
I must piggy back because the thing that I resent a little bit,
I was a little bit,
he said,
I'm not even allowed to think.
It's a little weird and a little strange.
And I do find it a little weird.
I've known him as Bruce Jenner,
and by the way,
I wish I had his body because I'd be,
no,
not now.
Just before Jesus.
Even before.
Do you ever see him walking around Malibu?
It's a disaster.
Barbri.
Neglect.
Oh yeah.
It was just the whole thing is falling.
He was taking the estrogen dude,
give him a break.
How long was he doing that?
They apparently for a very long time.
Really like how long I heard 20 years isn't making money.
Yes.
It's crazy.
So she was letting that beautiful,
that beautiful machine.
It was just putting on a layer of feminine fat and that's fine.
Whoa,
am I,
am I bad?
I'm not a bad person,
you know,
like support anybody.
I protect him.
I protect anybody's right to do what they want like that,
but I'm allowed to feel,
it's a little strange.
I'm allowed to kind of go,
I have to call him miss now he got a boob job,
right?
Yeah.
It's weird.
I'm just think about it.
He's got kids and I feel for his kids.
I'm sure they are accepting or whatever,
but it's gotta be weird.
Even Kristen Beck said,
it is weird.
I can't even figure it out myself.
You know?
I don't know.
It is weird.
It's definitely weird and I think that anything that you can't make fun of this
bullshit.
Like if you can't make fun of it,
you can,
you can make fun of everything.
You can make fun of jobs,
you can make fun of sex,
you can make fun of gender,
you make fun of transgender,
you make fun of everything.
Don't say he can't make fun of it because that's,
that's nonsense.
Then you're,
you're losing out on free speech.
And by the way,
the best way,
the best way to marginalize something is to not be allowed to talk about it.
Like it's you,
you change the thing,
you make it a sacred thing.
You don't make it a thing that you could talk about and discuss.
So you don't even know if the thing that you're talking about,
if it's,
if it's honest,
are we being honest about what is happening here?
Because for every person who does everything in life,
that's weird.
There's gonna be people that love it and there's going to be people that hate
it,
but you don't know what it is until everybody sits down and talks about it.
Like,
why is this
kid wants so much fucking tension?
Oh,
he's an attention whore.
And we figured out and we all discuss it when it comes to sexual things,
sexual aspects of behavior,
then we get ultra super sensitive.
Yeah.
We get really sensitive,
much more sensitive than anything else we do.
Whether it's behavior,
whether it's occupation.
When you get down to sexual and gender things,
people like,
well,
Whoa,
whoa,
whoa.
Don't talk about that.
You can make fun of lawyers all you want.
We probably going to need lawyers,
but you can make all the dead lawyer jokes you fucking,
you want,
you can throw lawyers in the bottom of the ocean.
You could talk about gunning them all down the streets.
Like dogs.
You could be a fucking blogger for like the Huffington post and you should say,
damn the lawyers,
we should gunned them down like dogs.
And you could say that and no one is going to get angry at you and no one's
going to march against you and no one's going to call it.
[inaudible] is a blog called kill all the lawyers.
It's taken from Shakespeare.
You Go,
now imagine if you said kill all the transgender people.
Like,
whoa.
Well what if a transgender dude sucked your Dick?
And uh,
you found out about it and you were really mad.
So you started a blog,
kill all the transgenders.
Like what the fuck man?
No people would,
people would freak out because when you want to kill somebody based on sex or
gender,
if you have anger towards them because of sex or gender becomes very charged.
Very child.
Did I mention that?
Did I mentioned that there was a guy,
I'm acting class,
he used to dress in drag and a very beautiful,
amazing and was very elegant.
And I always elegance a good word.
He was an elegant man.
And,
and one day he goes,
he looked at me and I had done a scene in acting class and he said that was sexy
baby.
And I go,
Oh yeah,
you think so?
You Better Watch out.
And he goes,
you better watch out.
Put Your Dick Cannon balls in my mouth up.
I got told us,
he just turned on me.
I was like,
what?
I put,
I put them,
I put them all in.
Whoa.
I thought I talked about on my podcast what to Dick and balls in my mouth.
Oh,
that's a lot of,
that's okay.
That's impressive.
It's probably hurt my balls,
but yeah,
that wouldn't be comfortable.
I don't think so.
His teeth for sure.
It was very normal size by the way.
I took a look.
Maybe he's like snakey stretched out ligaments or some shit.
He ended up being,
actually we dated for awhile.
Whoa.
How I turned out he wasn't to do,
but it's um,
there's like a weird charge.
Like racial hate is very similar in a way.
You know,
like there's a lot of charge to racial hate,
but there's some racial hate and kind of get away with like black people can say
some pretty nasty shit about white people and we let it slide.
You know like I saw this guy's Twitter,
some Spanish guy and he is a journalist and he was like,
ah,
I'm happy when all white shows get canceled.
And Mike,
could you imagine if someone said that about black shows?
Yeah,
you can't,
you know,
because Shelly,
why shabby?
Cause it's a,
an overpopulation but it's the point being,
it's like,
you know,
Cain Velasquez has this brown
pride shirt or brown pipe tattoo doesn't have white power.
He has well pride.
He has brown pride tattooed on his chest.
If you had white pride tattooed on your chest,
you would never be able to fight in the UFC.
True.
It's interesting.
You'd definitely have to explain yourself.
Yeah,
I mean I don't,
I don't think it's wrong because I think the sentiment behind it is right.
You know,
the sentiment about it behind it is that like,
like why are you proud about being white?
We're everywhere.
Let's relax.
Just relax.
I have to power relaxed.
And why are you upset that he's proud?
He's Mexican.
Relax.
You know?
But it's,
it's,
it's a double standard.
It is absolutely a double standard,
but it's the correct one.
It's interesting.
Yeah.
You know,
it's like things that's why things can't be,
can't be cut and dry.
It can't be the same for everybody because it's just not the same for everybody.
Now.
And what's interesting is that white,
I would imagine,
I think when they,
when California couldn't pass that proposition on gay marriage,
a lot of the opposition came from the black and brown communities because
especially Latino community is very religious.
Ari Shapiro to be a great joke about,
oh,
they did.
He had a great joke about he's dead right,
that African Americans voted like it was disproportionate amount of the voted
against gay marriage.
But again,
that can be granted and religion,
mission,
all those things you fear,
you know?
So there's a lot of nonsense when it comes to that stuff.
And I think all that's like,
again,
that's starting to dissolve.
I think it's starting to dissolve and I think even like the backlash that people
are getting for,
you know,
like,
like I guess the UFC is a big one.
That's a big target.
Hear about that all the time.
Like the anti violence aspect of it or anything else that people enjoy that is
very violent,
whether it's football or any other contact sport.
There's a lot of people that like really resist it and think that it's
detrimental to society.
And I think the contrary,
I think it's actually very good for it.
I worry more about when,
whenever you're trying to empower a group of people,
very vocally and verite with great energy.
Um,
sometimes what I worry about is,
and it happens all the time,
is you end up being somewhat tyrannical to another group of people.
Yeah.
Uh,
those people that might not understand what you're doing,
those people that have a religious reservations to what you're doing or all
whatever their reasons or just it doesn't sit right with them or they think it's
weird or they think it's unnatural.
I was talking to a 77 year old man about this Bruce Jenner thing,
and he's a good man.
And he goes,
it's unnatural.
We're celebrating the unnatural.
It's not a nurse.
I'm not saying it is,
I'm just saying,
but what I'm saying about it is it's,
it occurs enough,
right?
So that,
you know,
it's not unnatural.
It's just,
anyway,
I didn't get into it with them.
What I'm saying is that,
that everybody has their point of view and sometimes,
for example,
I think if you look at TV and stuff,
and I actually think we've become very intolerant of male behavior,
not the traditional prototypical masculine behaviors,
but sexual behavior as well.
So I think a lot of men are really afraid to sound even remotely.
Like they like having sex a lot with different women,
even if they're single,
cause there'll be called a creep,
let me call the scumbag.
We called all these things.
Would that used to be something that was actually celebrated?
And if you look at TV,
a lot of TV show,
especially mainstream TV,
if a guy's on that show and he has,
I don't know,
God forbid he's got a girlfriend and another girlfriend forget that that's
there.
But if he has five different women that he's sleeping with,
um,
you don't see that often.
You just don't see cause then we know a lot of guys you,
especially when we were younger who were that kind of masculine bent that put up
a lot of numbers you don't see,
I haven't seen too many of those characters on mainstream TV and if you do,
they are crucified.
They're just dirt bags.
And I think that's interesting.
I don't think that used to be the case as much.
I think that will go.
A lot of men are afraid to talk about sex the way women have for a long time.
I've noticed that the same thing.
It's like because women have been more marginalized,
their sexuality has been more of something.
Countries shamed there.
If they're sluts,
they're like Kim control from that sex and the city.
She was a very loose woman.
She was out there running around all willy nilly having sex with a bunch of
different gentlemen.
I mean,
but that was celebrated.
Like she was empowered because she was this cougar who's running around.
Yeah.
She's running around fucking all these guys and suck their dicks and bathrooms,
doing a bunch of dark,
dirty net naughty shit.
And it was great.
But if there was a show about a guy who did that with a bunch of women,
and then the thought less of the women after he was done with them,
you would go,
what?
A piece of shit.
And he wants to watch the show.
So what a woman could do by just getting done with guys fucking them and tossing
them aside,
no one cares.
There's virtually no backlash whatsoever.
But if a man,
yeah,
but if a man has the exact same behavior,
he's a piece of shit.
It's fascinating.
It is fascinating because with the woman were essentially watching like a
superhero or watching a woman who's turned the tables.
Now she's the Predator and the men of the prey.
Yeah,
you go curl,
you get 'em and after they'd done throw fucking throw their phone away,
delete,
delete all of their text messages from your phone,
delete their number and never call him again.
Fuck him.
Move on,
girl.
She becomes this.
But if you know,
if a woman did that to a man,
he'd be like,
oh wow.
Or amended that to a woman.
He'd be like,
God,
what a Dick that guy is.
But again,
that's artificial.
That's,
that's not natural.
That's kind of a lie too.
That's kind of where there's girls out there like that.
I'm saying that when,
when,
that's when,
that's kind of like when it's at,
it's a suggested.
That's how women really are all of all women.
You got,
well,
what we,
we're a lot more complicated than that and not really,
well,
I think if I had a friend that got done over by a girl at Kim control and she
never called back,
I would laugh
my dick off.
I would think it would be so funny.
I would talk to him about it every day.
I'd be like,
so she never called you again.
I'm going to college.
She just dumped you like it would be funny to guys guys done to me.
I had it done to myself,
said to me maybe three times,
one by a pretty famous a woman and I I,
yeah.
And I was like,
I was like,
excuse me.
how dare you,
you don't want more of this.
It's hard of you man.
You're tired of your bullshit.
That's normal too.
Or they just got tired of me in general in bed to get back to that Bruce Jenner
thing,
the Caitlyn whatever he's going to call himself,
call me,
call her.
She's,
I don't even know how much is true and how much is not true.
Cause I was listening to this radio show and they were talking about how he
underwent a 12 hour surgery to change his face more feminized it.
I do not know if that is the truth or not,
but who cares?
That's my take on it.
My take on it is,
I think it's cute.
I think we don't let him do whatever he wants to do.
I mean he's not interesting to me.
Well,
what if he ran interesting too,
isn't he getting the,
is he worthy?
Arthur Ashe award at the espys for courage.
Okay,
well it's kind of courageous,
but it's not like it's not a person that's been seeking attention by any means
necessary for a long time.
It's not like we're now talking about a guy was on a reality show for a long
time and now this is a reality show.
It's also,
it's like we're not being honest about the gentleman in question because the
woman in question.
So that's what I felt when I saw him on the cover of Vanity Fair with that
airbrushed and everything.
I went,
well,
more power to you if you want to do that.
But that feels a little bit like spectacle.
I mean,
what does he do?
He just lives this nonsense life on television.
I mean this is,
this is a guy that we're celebrating,
right?
Like the only thing that's interesting is that he doesn't want to be a man
anymore.
That's the interesting aspect of him.
That's right.
Everything outside of that is not interesting.
I agree.
He lives this really bizarre life.
I just can't imagine anybody who didn't need it,
want to live like that.
We have a microscope up your ass on this weird show and you're,
you're,
you're living out these false scenarios that are planned by producers.
So today we went to try to figure out what's wrong with the washing machine.
The fuck you did.
You know,
this is all nonsense.
it's nonsense.
So this guy has been on this nonsense show for x amount of years,
just it's,
it's really bizarre way to like put yourself out there,
right?
And then he decides that he's a woman and that becomes the most interesting
aspect of him.
Right.
Way More interesting than anything that he had ever done before other than win
the gold medal in the decathlon.
And he was a great athlete,
but like nobody cared.
Like everybody wanted to pay attention to his daughter.
Everybody wanted to pay attention to the mom.
And Bruce Jenner was like,
like this poor,
sad character that was hanging around the show that I was just thinking was
emasculated.
You know,
like he's in my love that the new Ben did.
Oh,
don't tell anybody I won't.
But he did her pet and he opened.
By the way,
thanks for opening for me.
My boy Joe Rogan drives all the way down on no sleep and open both shows for me.
Talk about a friend.
Meanwhile,
that bit I got,
I was watching,
I had to go on to an hour after you and I was like,
that is a hell of a bit.
Oh thanks man.
Dude,
it's better today
because it's so new.
And I thought I went,
I wonder what this is going to really turn into.
Good.
I enjoy doing it because it's got so much going on.
Took me out of my shell,
but helped me too.
I'd rather watch this right now.
That was a fun of taping her show is excellent.
Well Fun.
Really Fun.
Thanks everybody for coming down.
I'm was so cool.
Um,
so back to the Bruce Jenner thing.
I think if it encourages more people to do that,
if that's the real calling,
great,
great.
I know people that have changed genders and they're very happy.
That's totally possible.
It's totally possible.
Did.
The biggest thing too is that apparently the suicide rate for kids who feel this
way is very high.
Like according to Chris and Beck,
it was,
it's 45% of something crazy.
So it's just hard.
It's hard to be a normal person,
a hard to be a person,
like a normal white male in America who's not poor.
So normal like middle of the rope or it's very difficult for,
so imagine being marginalized.
I mean,
imagine,
just imagine where we're already,
there are just a group of people you've never met who hates your guts and
actually some who would actually kill you will.
You can,
you can feel that if you want.
There's certain neighborhoods where you can go in there as a white man and
you'll be a victim.
You'll be like an instant victim.
They'll target you.
I mean there's,
there's parts of the world where that's absolutely true.
There's parts of America,
I'm sure that's absolutely true,
but overwhelmingly you got an easy as fuck,
easy as fuck.
So when you have it easy as fuck,
sometimes I think it's easy to take for granted.
Someone who doesn't,
not necessarily saying that Bruce Jenner didn't have it easy because you know,
you watch him on that show,
he's not struggling.
It's just weird,
you know?
But there's people in,
in this world that are going through all sorts of pain for no fault of their
own.
They're just born in a shitty household.
They just born with the wrong human beings,
guarding over them and raising them and communicating with them and they're
fucked from birth.
And that's something that nobody wants to admit.
Well,
that,
that's also kind of always how I've looked at things where I was born on third
base and told her on home,
you know,
I'm a white American male in 2015 it gets some pain and good looking.
I got a ridiculous line shredded and I get paid to make people laugh.
I mean,
I get paid to make people laugh and I'm healthy.
Well you also,
you what's attractive about,
um,
people that have a situation like that is that you're appreciating it.
Ah,
you know,
when we talked to comics that whine about how many shows they have to do or that
they can't get the sit-com made or they can't,
you know,
man,
it's business.
You know,
I'm just
talking fucking agents,
you know,
have those conversations with people make you're exhausted,
lack of perspective,
you're exhausting.
Pick up a history book or a newspaper.
The also,
I think people are in this weird position,
actors are perpetually in this position and comics are in this position to a
certain extent because they want to have sitcoms and things along those lines.
You have to be chosen,
you have to be chosen.
You know,
Someone has to say,
I'm going to hire Brian,
count for my show and you're going to make him a star.
Whereas what's going on now for the first time ever is people are doing podcasts
that are turning them into famous people.
The you guys are famous from that fucking podcast,
the fighter and the kid is a giant podcast.
Yeah.
I mean you were already famous before that and Shabazz already famous for the
USA,
but there is a coalescence,
there's this crazy energy behind you guys and that show that I see all the time
that when I was opening for you on your show,
when you were filming your comedy special,
the audience was filled with those fighter and the kid shirts crazy.
I saw,
I don't know how many I saw and I saw all the different models,
the how,
the different ones you have.
And so I think what would a guy like you gets to do that?
A lot of guys don't,
don't have that opportunity is you get to just be yourself.
You get to be yourselves,
right?
And you don't have to worry about the decisions of these other people that are
trying to cast you are pro no deals to be.
That's where all the frustration seems to come from those guys.
It's all about dealing with other people and that's what acting is all the time.
What acting is all the times getting chosen.
When you,
when you can become,
come on somebody else's words,
words,
somebody else's clothes and somebody else's story.
If you could become autonomous and you can get away from anybody else's opinions
and ideas that you have to,
they have to throw them into the soup,
then you're truly responsible for your own work.
And when you're truly responsible for whatever the fuck you're actually doing,
then you have a totally different kinds of connection to it.
So like he,
these guys had like,
they get angry about the business,
about the way the business is changing in a weird way.
Like you,
you really,
if you enjoy being a comic,
you really don't have to do anything else anymore.
I got all that in the back of the day.
It was just like,
boy,
I hope I can keep this comedy thing afloat until I get that Sitcom that every
want to get that Sitcom.
I remember that.
Yeah.
That's all anybody wanted.
I know it was the analog is the holy grail.
We would get mad when actors would fake it.
You know,
actress who put together some bullshit fucking generic act.
Yeah.
And you knew that all they had was this seven minutes they were faking to try to
get on a sitcom and everybody will like,
yeah,
he's an actor.
He's just an actor as an actor faking it.
Like we had this weird,
this,
these weird distinctions yet,
but the guys up there doing standup with some standup that he wrote,
but nope,
nope.
He's faking as fake and it's for acne.
It's just for acting and at the end result.
But you would get,
you know,
these people that would go up there and do that and you really could see that
they were like Tom Hanks and punchline.
Yeah.
Like acting like a stand up.
But then it's like,
well who the fuck should you be able to make?
Who are you to make that distinction?
Yeah.
You know,
why should you be able to make funny?
It's funny,
right?
So why,
how can you decide that he's not a real stand up?
Because he wanted to put together seven minutes.
He used to always tell me to stand up.
I worked so hard and acting.
I remember how hard like I'd be in class and I just worked at it and I would do
scenes and I would cry and I,
and then I just,
I don't know man.
It's what happened is I was just,
when I got a taste of real standup and then with the podcast and then I was
like,
man,
I got to go where I got to drive where and sit on a set for how long we'll do
five minutes of acting.
It's if people saw how movies are made,
I think they'd have a lot less referenced for the entire,
if prawsaud how coal was pulled out of the ground,
I think they'd appreciate it more.
I agree.
And then just go in to buy it and that's right.
A coal coal would be on the cover of people magazine.
Yeah.
It's just I don't enjoy the process.
I don't enjoy the process and I don't enjoy some of the actors.
I met a lot of actors or cools,
fuck,
but there's a lot of them that are a lot of fucking work,
like a brutal amount of work or communicating with them.
It's very frustrating and they're stressed out all the time.
They're there in this this thing where they're always trying to get approved.
They're always trying to get cast there,
was trying to get you and you've got to create a network that way.
You have to,
you know,
you're selling yourself and it's not easy and you're selling yourself as being
exactly like everybody else.
I mean there's like a hum that they all have.
They all the same frequency.
Hum.
They try to stay on that frequency.
They don't vary because they want those jobs.
They want to be,
they want to be,
they can have their own political opinions.
A lot of the times it just absorb this left wing ideology that seems to be
floating around Hollywood.
Yup.
I know it's a weird place,
but it's a weird place,
but I think it's fucking changing in a big way.
Man.
Ned,
I think everything's changing.
I think we're going to look back.
I think we're in the middle of the storm and uh,
I don't think we quite realize how significant some of the changes in culture.
I said it when,
when people are in an epoch,
when they're in an unchanging moment,
like the people who were coming into the renaissance didn't know they were in
the renaissance,
didn't call it the renaissance,
didn't know that there was something called the renaissance at that they were
even in the dark ages before that.
So there are countless examples of that where this is the most important date.
They weren't aware of that and they weren't aware of the bronze age then the,
the mental age and all that.
So you're living your life and those kinds of forces and trends and movements
are more subtle than that.
Yeah.
I think this one though is so crazy that it reveals a lot about the nature of
recognition.
Meaning like recognizing when things are weird because I don't think we're
recognizing it nearly
as much as it deserves.
What do you mean like,
well,
I think that you get used,
people get used to things.
It's like if you go like,
um,
Justin wren,
the UFC fighter,
it's been on this podcast a bunch of times,
he does the fight for forgotten a foundation that he created to go and build
wells.
So the pygmies,
you know,
he goes down there and build these pygmies as well.
It's just a great guy.
But those folks who live there,
that is their life and that is what they're used to.
Just like when we were on that Prince Edward Prince of Wales Island,
we,
that was our life for those five days.
Yeah.
That's one of the reasons why when I came back here,
it felt so good to realize that this is,
this feeling of signing your face is very pleasurable.
This feeling of being around people and having,
you know,
the convenience of grocery stores and restaurants that are good and,
and comedy clubs and the,
all the,
the good aspects that the city provides.
It made me like acutely aware of that because being in that environment that
could be like you,
you adapt to that.
People are super adaptation,
adaptation,
adaptive.
What does that look wrong?
Adoptation agitative no,
it is adaptive rafting,
but people are really,
really adaptive.
We can change and we can morph and we can,
and I think in some ways we're not aware of when it's happening.
It just becomes a normal life like text messages and photos and being able to
Google things becomes normal,
but I think historians,
when they look back on the era between 1994 and 2015 they will say a tornado of
information.
They will see an unprecedented amount of data that's being passed back and forth
to the point where at the end,
at the very end of the line with 2015 more data gets done in like an hour,
then more data gets passed by in 24 hours.
Then the entire history of the human race.
Yeah,
just stop and think about that.
It's incredible.
The entire history of the human race.
That's how much data we produce every day.
That mean when you all have the clients talking about the movement of
information,
I mean a lot of it's not an office,
by the way.
I don't know.
Those numbers are exactly correct.
It might be like two days or one day,
whatever the fuck it is.
It's some insanely small amount of time that represents the entire history of
human beings writing things down.
Most of his bullshit,
most of his Facebook messages and text messages and tweets.
But the bottom line is it's exchanges.
Okay.
It might be nonsensical social exchanges that don't mean anything.
Lol Tea.
It might be bullshit,
it might be Instagram pictures of your ass and yoga pants and might be nonsense.
But in that nonsense,
there's an unprecedented amount of tweets that are leading people to check out
articles that are leading people to maybe reform opinions or reconsider
preconceived notions.
And then you'll
start reading comments,
how other people agree or disagree and you start communicating with each other.
And the unprecedented sort of exchanges taking place,
I just don't think we know is to also bring,
it just happened while we were alive.
It's also humanizing a lot of those experiences.
So,
so,
so I think a lot when you frame like for example,
this Bruce Jenner thing,
when you frame it like an uh,
people really do understand that when you finally somebody says,
listen,
not only have I always felt this way,
but the overwhelming evidence is that anybody or most people who become
transgender or go through gender reassignment surgery,
if you look at how they always felt,
if you ask them,
they always felt this way.
Kind of like the way somebody who was gay generally usually will say,
I've always been attracted to the same sex.
So when you,
when you frame it that way and you see it and you see a person that you know is
very real to you in an acting the way everybody else does,
it's hard not to empathize.
It's hard not to have compassion.
So that,
that in that sense,
information is nudging us all together,
all closer or at least at least I think you're right.
We are becoming nicer,
more gentle.
We want understand it.
Yeah.
We're becoming more aware of our,
of our similarities as opposed to differences.
Yeah.
Focusing on our differences.
I think the similarities,
what's,
what's super important,
like the core,
the core process is how we treat each other.
That's what's super important.
And if we're treating each other in a negative way simply because of some ideas
that we might have on who a person should or shouldn't be,
whether or not you should sleep with men like that,
that's one of the best ones.
Like the,
or whether or not like I retweeted something from,
um,
the 1930s,
I believe it was,
where a woman was going to jail for being a lesbian.
It's a crazy picture,
Jamie.
See if he could pull it up.
It's,
uh,
it's on my,
my Twitter feed somewhere not that far down.
It's from a old picks archives.
It's from 1940 when as a kid it was a crime to be a homosexual.
And this woman,
you know,
she's,
uh,
they're,
they're given her a mugshot for being a lesbian.
It's like,
just think about that.
That's not that long ago,
man.
So it was at 75 years ago.
Look at that.
That's horrible.
Yeah.
That's scary to think of,
man.
That that,
that's how how fucked up people can be.
That's how ignorant people could be.
We just,
it hasn't been that long.
It hasn't been that long since we've had civilization.
No,
it's only been a few thousand years.
It really,
I mean,
the civilization they have a few thousand years ago too,
by the way.
You can keep it.
Yeah,
you can keep it.
Do you mean before anesthesia?
Antibiotics,
put the fucking Romans all the horrible shit that you heard people did back then
and war and that,
that's a really interesting point because the Romans and the models that,
you know,
back then it was,
it was excused enough to just to say,
I'm stronger.
I own you.
Oh,
and by the way,
slavery was the order of the day.
You took human beings as property.
Always.
Nowadays,
what's interesting is that when any country does something that's bad,
uh,
Russia in Ukraine,
it couldn't just say they were trying to annex territory.
They justify what they were doing into the,
the,
the Putin regime justifies what they're,
what they're doing be on,
on,
on the idea that,
look,
we're just protecting our Russian people that are there.
No matter who you're talking to,
no matter what country you're talking to in the matter is Syria,
when they're bombing the rebels,
whatever.
Syria,
the Assad regime,
we'll talk about the fact that they are protecting a lot of different
communities in a very diverse country,
et cetera,
et cetera.
And what I think is interesting is that with so many people watching anybody
who's doing anything that could be considered violent,
uh,
you know,
murderous,
bad in general must be justified along moral grounds.
It's no longer allowed to say,
we're fucking taken over your country because we're,
Romans and Romans are better.
That used to be all the excuse they needed were Romans.
We have a right to everything.
We can see it belongs to us because we are superior and everyone else is not.
So they can either die,
get out of the way or be our slaves.
Well,
that was the only way you survived.
But then as if you were the stronger one with that attitude because that was the
attitude that you were going to encounter.
Yeah,
like the,
the what the Mongols did when they found a new civilization,
like when they found the pope,
the first contact with the pope was saying,
oh,
we're aware that you weren't aware,
but this is the great Khan,
the Great Khan runs everything.
So you're going to have to pay some fucking tribute and bowed down or you're all
dead.
Like that's it.
It's how it goes.
And that was what they did.
They,
they believe they ruled over everything on the earth,
like didn't have a territory,
what territory,
what the whole thing.
They wanted the whole earth.
And that was the standard operational behavior of like the classic marauders.
Yeah.
From a thousand to,
I mean that was the 12 hundreds imagine it was like a thousand years before that
where they were really savages or 2000 years before the,
it raises questions about whether this stuff is endemic to human beings.
Like they,
they were doing the study on chimps and they have a lot of evidence.
They've already seen it,
but they have a lot of evidence,
even like from past chimps that you know,
different when they studied different areas and communities that a group of
large,
a large group of males will come in and,
and overrun a smaller group of males in an isolated area and kill them,
beat the fucking shit out of him,
kill him,
and come in and either kill the kids or you know,
have sex with a women.
Very human,
like behavior.
Very typical.
And it used to be that the idea that human beings were violent like that was
because we didn't know any better and that it wasn't a natural impulse.
In fact,
uh,
we're not naturally violent because kids aren't.
Uh,
and so that's a learned behavior problem is you see that kind of behavior in the
animal world.
You see it among dolphins and you see it among chimps and you certainly see it
in spades in indigenous cultures that have had very little contact with other
cultures,
had not shared information with other cultures.
Well,
if there's no civilization,
if you don't have an infrastructure,
if you don't have foods coming in and then you see you have struggle and when
you have struggle,
you have danger.
When you have danger,
you have people that are going to take advantage of people that are weaker than
them and you,
you have a breakdown of what we consider civilization.
I mean,
and when you get into these really rural communities like the further and
further back in time,
the more and more prevalent that shit's going to be.
That's the way p scarcity also changes the way your brain behaves.
Oh,
of course.
You get competitive.
It gets super dangerous.
I think that people are capable of amazing feats of kindness and people are
awesome to be around and people are also unfucking believably evil.
Yeah.
Like if you look at that isis video,
I didn't watch it,
but it was described to me of the Jordanian pilot who was lit on fire.
They did it in slow mo from different angles.
I mean,
they filmed it,
they set it up,
they set up a shot,
and then they filmed this guy getting burned to death.
The fact that people are capable of that kind of cruelty to each other.
And at the same time there's selfless people that are out there like Justin
wren,
who's living with the pygmies in the Congo and he's digging wells for them.
Well,
they always say human beings,
not all day,
but that the book our inner ape,
he,
the author says that we are a bipolar ape.
We're a bipolar AYP capable of incredible cruelty,
incredible kindness,
incredible acts of destruction,
incredible acts of beauty.
Uh,
and that's the,
that is called the problem of humanity.
That is exactly what we are.
We're this,
well,
we're also in this constant state of struggle.
And I think one of the things that people are like the,
the,
the negative push that I totally understand against masculine thinking and
masculine behavior is that we're moving towards this more aware,
more sensitive,
more or kind society.
And the further you move away from those roots of the ancient barbarians,
the better off we're going to be.
Maybe,
maybe,
but I would also suggest that male aggression and fucking playing on your belt.
I'm playing on my belt as I'm talking about this and I'll talk around male
aggression.
That's like,
it's funny how different tellers naturally to hose.
I'll tell you what,
boys can do some pull up a chair bars.
How many guys do that?
They pull up their belt and they got about Tyson.
I'm serious.
Listen here.
Don Frye.
Tell you what,
let's that's a man's man.
That's a management saw him yesterday.
I was,
I,
I obsessed.
Um,
but I think aggression
has also given us so many of the goodies.
Uh,
you want to go through the list of heaps of fresh vegetables in the middle of
the wintertime.
Um,
all the inventions that push us beyond our biology,
they takes,
it requires a little aggression.
I think sometimes,
and even,
God forbid I say it,
competition,
ruthless competition.
Uh,
that's how things progressed.
The problem with that is that people are going to lose and people don't like
losing cause they think losing is a bad feelings.
So they think of competition and competitive people as being negative.
Okay.
So that's what,
that's my worry about the feminization quote unquote of our society.
I think that we have to be very careful that we,
we don't forget the positive aspects of what you'd call unoriginal,
macho energy.
I think the problem is that it's not masculine energy.
That's a problem that people are upset about.
I think it gets misconstrued.
I think the problem that we all have is with assholes.
Yeah.
That is the problem.
It's right across the board,
whether it's women or it's men.
When you see like these crazy radical feminists who a attack speakers because
they want to support men's rights in divorce court and whatever the fucking
reason is that the really aggressive,
like this is archetypal video of this super aggressive feminist outside of this
thing and Toronto and she's got red hair and she's screaming at people like what
she wants and what she doesn't want from men when they can shut the fuck up and
you know,
and she's telling people in the honest,
shut the fuck up the people that,
that that exist like that,
then they become the problem because the problem is not like the idea that women
deserve everything that men deserve and that we should have equal treatment by
law.
The problem is assholes.
Yeah.
It's assholes representing a point of view that I probably don't disagree with,
but I disagree with her and I disagree with someone who is generalizing about an
entire gender because that's ridiculous of course.
Or generalizing about a type of person that is in that gender.
Like you can't,
everybody is entitled to start from zero.
And as soon as you are prejudice,
whether you're prejudice against white people or whether you're prejudice
against men or whether you're prejudice against gays are transgenders or
whatever the fucking is,
as soon as you stop treating that person as like an we come at them from a
totally even spot,
then you're the asshole.
Right?
And I would suggest that,
you know,
we benefit also and enjoy a lot about life based on people who created things,
whose motives.
Their motives may have been less than stellar show.
A lot of people are driven by just pure ego,
domination,
greed,
and those things are not,
those things do not always create bad things.
In fact,
a lot of times they create incredible innovations,
better ways to do things.
You know so much.
What is,
what's another word for innovation?
Another word for innovation is destruction.
You're destroying how people used to do it.
When we came up with,
uh,
the combustion internal combustion engine and put it in a vehicle and turn it
into a car.
People that made a lot of money making buggy whips went out of fucking business.
I said,
I don't need your fucking Buggy whip because my car doesn't respond to buggy
whips.
It responds to what I call rock oil,
which turned out to be oil.
So,
you know,
that's the other thing to keep in mind.
Innovation is isn't aggressive.
It's competition thing.
It's competition.
It's destruction.
Well we,
you know,
we deal with that all the time with businesses,
right?
When businesses start to get pressure in the marketplace from other outside
businesses and you deal with this,
this weird thing that happens with a,
with commerce,
you know,
it becomes as does gigantic contest and some aspects of it,
we feel like we need to save.
Like that's what happened and that's why I'm thinking business,
right?
They go to the government and say,
yeah,
don't let us fail.
Well,
what's,
what's really interesting to me is like there's,
there's people that got bailouts,
right?
Like who got bailouts?
Almost all of the banks almost call them Sachs,
et cetera.
With the other businesses that got bail outs as well.
Or just banks,
the car,
the car industry was bailed out as well.
Turned out both cases.
By the way,
it turned out to be success stories to an extent.
They really,
Dave.
So they made the money and well,
GM especially has made some amazing fucking cars.
Yeah,
but how is your respect to the Ford didn't take any money.
They're like,
they were doing well enough and I don't remember why,
but they use trucks.
Yeah.
A Ford pickup trucks.
They sell a lot of fucking trucks,
dude.
Yeah.
Everywhere you go,
you go to like a hunting ranch or you go to a cattle ranches.
They drive those fucking F150 bulletproof what?
Bankrupt a lot of companies where their pension plans.
So you would retire,
they'd pay medical benefits for your entire family,
for the rest of your life.
And you got 95% of your salary.
I mean,
here's the,
uh,
here's the payoff.
So what is the,
the money?
549 billion.
That's how much they got.
Keeping my,
everybody keep in mind a billion.
A billion seconds is 33 years roughly.
So that's what,
that's how much $1 billion isn't it?
But they're not giving him seconds to giving them dollars.
Thousand million.
So 549 is that what it was?
549 billion.
Insane.
That hurts.
I believe the banks paid off that money though.
I'm sorry if I'm looking at those numbers.
For the most part,
they all paid it off.
The government made a lot of money off that deal.
Really?
Yes.
Cause they got interest.
Wow.
So they made actually a lot more money.
No Sham.
Yep.
The banks paid back.
What did they do?
What they earn that they got from it?
What happens is that then they pay it back with interest and no,
no,
no.
I run the government.
What does the government do with that money?
I don't really know.
Getting back to the people that paid the taxes due the it's,
it does things like builds roads and things I guess.
And maybe they don't have to account for it.
It's the most ridiculous system ever.
Well,
we know that when you throw money,
just money at a,
like in Baltimore,
I believe,
which is the worst school system in the country.
Uh,
I think we spend federal dollars that we spend more money on per student is the
third most amount of spending per student than any other town or state in the
union.
That's kind of amazing.
And guess what a d you can't just throw money at a problem know,
so,
so many of these issues that I'm kind of becoming fascinated with her don't
require money or it's not a democratic or republican issue.
For example,
one of the prob biggest challenges we're gonna face is that there are a lot of
people out there who don't fit into the 21st century economy.
They don't have skillset that requires that.
So you can,
they do manual labor or they do a minimum wage jobs.
You can raise the minimum wage to $15 an hour,
I guess.
I don't know what it's like to run a small business.
I know a lot of small business people say that's too much.
I don't know.
But that's actually not the problem.
Every time you hear Democrats or Republicans talking,
they say things like,
Hey man,
uh,
you know,
we gotta do something about this income inequality.
So the rich getting richer and the poor getting poorer and we got a tax,
the rich,
well everybody has their point of view.
No,
it trickle down economics problem is in fact that what's really going on is
technology is taking the place of a lot of these unskilled jobs and we are going
to have,
as technology grows exponentially,
robots and different forms of technology are going to take over so many of the
jobs that people have now.
Bus Drivers,
we're going to have autonomous vehicles.
I don't know when it's going to be,
but bus drivers will be out of business,
out of work and there are so many examples of that.
What we have to start doing rather than worrying about redistributing wealth.
The most important thing is getting these people ready for the 21st century
economy,
which is probably going to change all the time,
which means you got to figure out how you're going to fit in to an economy that
doesn't operate the way traditional economies work anymore.
There's just different needs,
different services.
Things are always changing.
Things are very trendy.
That's the biggest challenge and that's a hard fucking pill to swallow for
someone who loved their entire family's existence on horse shoes.
Damn right.
Also,
this goddamn engine thing comes along and no one needs a fucking horse shit.
You can't go to the government and say,
Hey,
government,
bail me out and give me subsidies for the rest of my life because somebody has
to pay for that and that's all of us.
And so taxes get higher and that's what we have to be careful of.
I,
I just really,
there is a place for government,
but you have to be careful of saying,
hey,
the government's gonna come in here and save the day.
It's,
it's a banquet way of thinking.
You've got to evolve gotta change.
You've gotta be honest.
You gotta be honest.
This is a,
this might be a skill that's no longer needed and robots are going to change
everything.
They are going to change everything.
And then when you get intelligent robots and you have like these robots slaves,
you're going to have robots that are going to do all your,
or
you're going to have absolute precise measurements on things.
You'll have a robot that's building houses like are like a human being built
houses but robots,
robots walking up stairs carrying gigantic bags of cement with no strain in
their back.
All manual labor jobs,
robots.
I don't think he has,
he ain't robot Santam comics guys.
So I think our jobs to say for at least our lifestyle,
we're lucky is fun.
Not just the obstacle mix but also that you can't,
you can't like fix that with a robot.
You can't make a robot funny.
But they have done some random joke generators,
but you know what?
They lack that,
that pop of the great bits.
Yeah,
the great bits.
It has this unique perspective,
like you're going to get a robot to mimic bill burr or I was going to say yes,
absolutely Joey.
Joey Diaz.
I was going to say Mitch Hedberg actually cause his absurd,
this point of view was like really only affective I think with his way of
communicating like his,
his style of delivery.
You know,
you're not going to figure that out with the computer.
You're just not,
not going to figure out why it's appealing.
It's um,
we're lucky shit being a person who was like getting out of school now and
thinking about jobs that used to exist just a short while ago that are nonsense
now they're just nonsense jobs.
Like how many people in the,
uh,
the era of,
you know,
1995 had some sort of training and school and education and technologically
related things and technology,
creative technology.
By the time they get out of school,
everything that they learned is irrelevant.
Didn't you have a problem with that,
Jamie,
to explain your problem?
I went to school to be like,
to work in a recording studio,
right.
And at worst maybe work in a radio station.
They would say,
and this is kind of like what my education has kind of turned into to be able to
control essentially a radio show,
but there are no recording studios for me to go work in.
They don't exist anymore.
There's maybe five in La,
there's probably a couple more than that,
but anyone that has been working there for last 15 years,
it's still working there.
They're not hiring new young blood to come in because they need to work for the
next 15 years.
You know what I mean?
But there's just not that much of a demand and they're not making music in the
video is either,
you can do it at home,
you can do it at home easy.
It used to have to have like these incredible systems.
Right.
And now you just have like a regular apple computer or even a windows computers
fine.
Right.
Dave girl's movie called like the sound city or something like that,
I believe came on a couple of years ago.
It's really good and kind of shows how that all happened over the last 10 years.
Yeah,
it's,
you're,
you're finding these houses for sale.
There's a lot of houses that have like recording studios built in them for sale,
but you don't need all that shit.
And Yeah,
there's a lot of those instances of,
um,
the technology,
the technology just doesn't wait for you.
Just if you,
if you learn computer programming pre 1990,
what are you gonna do today?
We didn't do stupid.
Yeah.
I mean do,
you're not
old schools.
It's,
um,
anything technologically related like banking on one thing over another.
Like somebody just invited me to some startup of some new,
um,
you know,
multimedia,
um,
social media sort of a thing like,
yeah.
And uh,
I remember thinking,
good luck with this.
Like good luck.
Like why would I invest in,
in my time to try to go check out,
go to a speech and see like the unveiling of this thing.
Like if it's good,
it'll get online and I'll hear about it.
Yeah.
That's it.
Yeah,
that's it.
Yeah.
And you're not going to get behind anything before.
It's good.
Like you don't know why it is or why it isn't.
Who Said who's to say certain things catch on.
Certain things don't.
But you got to let them just catch on,
catch on.
Like I had some academics come to me because they had listened.
Yeah.
I have a lot of academics on my podcast.
They're all Brian Count jail and not the funding kid.
Uh,
but uh,
and I,
I had some academics come to me and say,
listen,
we want to put together a,
uh,
a convention as something called Evo Con.
So it's a convention on evolution and we want to get all the great minds of
evolution together and people that are saying and get together and have a
convention about evolution and with the idea that we can get that 40% of
Americans or whoever it is who don't believe in evolution over on our side,
let's give them the evidence because the scientific community science is
fascinating,
but they've done a very bad job communicating their message.
They don't do a good job communicating because what happens with academics and,
and people in that world is that they become very insular and they become very
incestuous.
And they are only talking to each other and they're not talking to people who
are casting votes and,
and who ultimately have say in public policy and stuff.
Well,
you know,
I learned from Kevin and photos on the podcast the other day who was a scientist
and works a lot with GM foods,
GMO foods and explaining what they really are.
One of the things he was talking about to me when,
um,
was that he works for the public.
Essentially he's a public scientist,
but when they research something or come to some conclusions,
they publish them in these papers or journals.
These journals are often hidden behind paywalls.
Yes.
So the,
the,
the very people that paid to fund these studies don't really have access to
them.
And there was a kid who could went to juvenile [inaudible] into um,
yes,
he killed diversity.
He,
they were,
yeah,
they were charging him with like some serious crime.
Is that Aaron Schwartz?
I think it was Aaron Schwartz.
Yeah.
That was easy.
He hacked into all these sort of academic papers that were not made public.
You know,
he made them pay for them.
They were,
they were put on,
you know,
you had to pay for many act and made in public without the professors
intellectual property.
They,
that's their intellectual property.
They didn't give a say so the university makes money off of it and he just gave
them to everybody and then they threatened
him to make an example in the,
ended up killing himself.
Um,
how do you feel about that?
That seems here more than a year.
I've just Swartz killed himself rather than face prosecution's questions about
Mit's handling of the case persist.
Yeah,
scroll down.
I feel as though,
I think Erin Schwartz,
what you,
you know,
if you,
if you have,
um,
if somebody has intellectual property,
it's an academic paper on something and they can make money off it,
they should be allowed to make money off it and it fits your property and
somebody comes in and breaks into your password and just gives it away for free.
That's,
that's not cool.
Right.
I think that's what he did.
I don't know.
I just,
but if you are a public scientist and if you are working for a university that
receives tax dollars from the community and you do this work,
doesn't that work belong to everyone?
Very good question.
Everyone paid for it.
If they're not,
how are you public?
If you are,
you're getting money and you're earning money from the money that was put up by
the public to pay for you.
I mean you have to kind of define 100% we allow what we don't allow.
So in some ways he probably had a really good point.
The way went after it was kind of theft.
I mean he invaded someone's property,
which is the university to whether or not it should be their property.
That's debatable.
But the fact that he,
he wasn't allowed into their servers and he got in there,
all he did was download some stuff.
So it's not malicious.
I think whatever crime they should have a pointed at him would have been like
nothing.
Like a fine.
Maybe say,
hey man,
you can't just break into peoples,
can't just hack into people's servers.
That is fucked up.
So he should get some sort of fine for that.
But the idea of jail time mean I'm talking about like a $500 fine or $1,000 or
something like that and put him on probation.
So you don't ever do this again,
man.
You can't can't hack into people's.
But the idea that this guy was under so much stress that he killed himself over
releasing academic papers,
which clearly there's no malice involved.
We're not trying to hurt anybody,
threaten him with I think life in prison.
I mean they threatened her,
something terrible and he's trying to release things that make people smarter.
You know,
he's trying to put more of that out there and then you do the math and you go,
well how did this stuff get funded?
Did it get funded by taxpayers?
So why the fuck do we have to pay for it?
Why don't have to pay for the results of these pubs studies?
Yeah.
Pub Med studies or whatever the fuck they know.
If somebody publishes something in a paper and it was funded by taxpayers,
should be available,
should be in a public library somewhere.
What it is this guy talk about as far as GMO is,
I mean there's a lot of misinformation out there,
right?
Yeah.
He was expensive,
so long,
long podcasts.
We did three full hours and he was great.
He's a really a really interesting guy and man,
people have some crazy misconceptions and they stick to them like glue.
No matter what he said on the podcast and what he explained in the podcast.
You see people arguing with it online or religious,
their religion,
a lot of list about it.
Yeah.
They don't understand what it means to modify these foods,
like these ideas of Frankenfoods,
these ideas of what's dangerous and deadly.
It's something that people have been doing forever.
They just been doing it and he was explaining how they were splicing plants
together and creating hybrids of plants and that they would take,
you know,
the cars.
Sometimes they require less pesticides,
but he's so he's saying when he's talking about it,
this has been done forever.
Yeah.
And it's like the difference being that now their engineering,
certain things to turn on genes or turn off genes are,
and people are concerned that this could be really dangerous.
And he was really honest about it,
man.
He's like,
yes.
I'm like,
she just should be some concern.
And he was really honest about the whole idea of we yell,
we don't exactly know that this is going to be safe for everybody at every
single turn every time.
But if you just look at the things we were going over,
the things that kill people right now,
like peanuts and Brian has a fucking a allergy to penicillin.
And My mother does too.
She'll die if my mother,
my mother eats one,
Brazil nut,
one shall die.
That's crazy.
So think of that.
Just imagine if that was a drug,
if that was a drug that was released by the pharmaceutical company,
would those numbers be tolerated?
Boy,
I don't think so.
So if it's a common atory plant or vegetable,
something that they've created and it wax out one person out of 100 million,
should that be okay?
I don't think it should,
but man,
that's a tough cost.
It's a tough that we meet this calls all the time.
Asks Kills Aspirin.
Kills a number of people.
Thousands of people out here.
Yeah.
Now you're,
nobody in their right mind is going to ban aspirin.
It's a great drug and helps a lot of people with chronic pain.
Did a lot of people drink too much water and die from that every year like
anything is is that's queen is toxic in a certain quantities.
That's a fact.
But the thing about this is that people are worried about cancer because they're
worried about what they're doing to these plants are not natural and that's how
they're able to fight off these pesticides and it's a legitimate concern when
you look into what's actually going on and actually being done.
I think most of the plants that were worried about when it comes to that stuff,
I think those are the ones that they feed to animals and then you're worried
about,
okay,
now you're eating the animal that's eating this stuff that has this roundup shit
on it.
Like what is,
what's that?
What's going on there cause like,
like we were talking about bears like if you eat a bear that's been eating
blueberries,
it's supposed to be like the most delicious meat in the world.
Steve Rinella talks about this.
He had a an episode where he shot this bear in Alaska and as he's butchering the
bear,
the bear fat has blue.
It's a blue hue,
like almost a purple hue because of the blueberries is things have been eating
well.
Who's to say that if you're giving a fucking cow or you're giving a some
whatever animal,
some this roundup shit.
If it's in,
if you're spraying it on vegetables to kill bugs and then those vegetables get
fed,
are you washing them before you give them your cows?
Like how exactly you treating them and make sure there's nothing in there.
If there is something in there,
just like how the blueberry makes the bear tastes different,
that's
got to do something to what you're eating.
It's just gotten too,
it just got to be affecting the flesh that you're taking into your body.
And there's a potential,
if you're eating toxic shit,
if that is like the,
the,
that cow is eating some pesticides that's gotta be able to get into the meat.
So maybe they'll yoga lady was right.
Wayne,
Mandy toxic mag.
I mean look,
if you look at it that way,
she got kind of almost has a point.
If you're not getting like free range grass fed roundup,
is that bad?
If indeed it does get in the meat,
if indeed it does.
What kits,
quantity to a quantity that affects you?
We,
I don't know.
Did you ever see the um,
there was uh,
uh,
one of these shows where this guy had offered to drink round up.
He had said is totally safe.
You don't have to worry about it.
He goes,
I would drink it.
And the guy who is he drinking?
Yeah.
Well I've got a glass here,
drink it.
And the guy goes,
well you're just being a total jerk.
And he leaves.
He said,
watch it.
Cause it's hilarious.
I did drink.
I don't know if it was round.
Watch this.
Let's,
let's hold up.
Just start it from the beginning and give us a volume cause this is wonderful.
I love this,
but he's leave
that glyphosate in Argentina is causing increases in cancer.
You can drink a whole quart of it and it won't hurt you.
It's to drink some.
We have some here.
I'd be happy to.
Actually,
not.
Not really,
but I know it wouldn't hurt me.
I have some guns.
I'm not stupid,
but I know that's dangerous.
No.
People tried to commit suicide that it would fail fairly regularly.
Tell the truth.
It's dangerous to humans.
No,
it's not.
So are you ready to drink when I'm in class,
I'm not an idiot.
Interview me about Golden Rice.
That's what I'm talking about.
Okay,
then it's finished.
Then the interview is finished and say that's a good way to sell things
here.
Come on man.
You're a complete jerk.
He got mad quickly,
didn't it?
Yeah,
of course he did.
You dare me.
I'm going to have to probably drink it while on there.
He's a liar.
The guy who they were,
they were,
they were spraying the trees.
I,
it was California,
the orange trees for fruit flies or whatever.
And he started the meeting.
Uh,
he was the owner of the company.
He started the meeting by drinking an entire glass of it.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
And carried on.
He goes,
so here's how dangerous it is.
Ready guys,
go cluck,
cluck,
and it's doesn't taste good or whatever.
Boom.
And that was a famous way started that sort of like to prove to everybody that
this product is not toxic.
Okay.
But then how's it killed bugs?
Well,
I think bugs,
I don't know,
but I,
I do know that a town,
usually it will attack the bugs central nervous system or something or causes
some,
it fucks with one enzyme.
I would like to talk to you today.
What if he's turning into the flaw?
Exactly.
She just got really thick hair and he's strong as shit.
It just gets,
and he throws up stuff on his food and start fucks all the time.
Jeff Goldbloom was just,
it was fun to feel great movie,
great movie.
It's a great God damn movie.
Goldblum is about seven eight.
He's a giant fan.
Huge.
Fucking huge.
He's so talented,
man.
I love him.
And Jurassic Park and impossible Dick.
Whoa.
He's got an in possible dick on them.
How big I hear it's so,
first of all,
there are two things that he has going for him.
And I know girl dated him and I dated her for about 10 minutes and she said,
well,
he plays the piano concert piano.
He's a,
he's a concert pianist,
basically,
and he's got a donkey dick.
And I thought,
I said,
of course.
I went,
Whoa,
hold on.
I stop everything.
Fuck his piano.
Let's get it.
Let's get to his dick immediately,
immediately.
And I had to,
I had to ask her and she,
she showed me her forearm.
She said,
it's as big as my forum.
Whoa.
And Monster Hall.
And I said,
and of course then I said,
you,
you slut.
How dare you?
I said,
who's better than dead?
And she goes,
I'm not going to talk about that.
Well,
you lost there.
I definitely lost to the six foot six talking tick piano playing richest shit
successful as fuck.
If you watch that movie the fly,
you'll get an idea of how he fucks too.
Yeah.
He's kind of,
he's a,
he's a stud.
He's got an easy bone structure,
so I love him in Jurassic Park is one of my all time favorite roles are his,
he's just great.
Yeah,
he's an interesting,
he just,
he wasn't a region of the body snatchers.
Yes,
I do know that.
You know,
I was uh,
it was amazing.
It was like,
God,
what is he like 20.
He also had a very tiny part in Annie Hall.
Ah,
Yup.
He was an almost an extra and uh,
got us unique.
Yeah.
He's a bad motherfucker.
He's great as a scientist too because as a scientist he has like all these
unique quirks about the way he describes things and processes,
things you totally believe he's intelligent enough to be making like in the fly.
It's a perfect example.
Could you imagine like a dull actor playing that role?
Like what he's,
what he's,
when he's pitching it and he's passionate about it,
like that excitement,
like you really believe it,
you will business.
Oh,
he's the guy who created that,
that transporter.
This also,
that kind of a thing he does is tiny.
He's on,
I was thinking about it as he talks about it.
I just wear the same clothing all the time and pick it up from last time because
I,
the way I don't have to think about,
but I believe that we do.
I'm saying he's,
he's one of those guys were,
while he's doing it on stage or in a,
in a,
you know,
on the movie you,
you really believe you will forget that it's Jeff Goldblum.
Even for brief moments,
like he's good enough that it just hypnotizes you and then you're like,
wow,
he can fucking kicked ass in that one.
Yeah.
There's only a few of those people out there we'll walk in is probably that way
too.
Just like,
I know that's a,
that's a name from the past.
Very Donald when they Dunaway Chinatown Watch Chinatown with chocolate.
So God damn,
she could act phenomenal movies as Christ.
She was good.
So it was heat too much.
Jesus Christ.
That's a good movie.
What's his name in the movie,
Hank or something?
I don't remember.
I forget it.
Hank.
It's Chinatown.
Fuck.
She's my mother.
No,
she's my daughter.
She's my sister.
She's my daughter.
I remember that.
Or He's slapping her face.
John cut his nose.
Sliced his nose for for 10 points.
You know
who actually cut his nose?
No,
that was Roman Polanski.
Really?
That was the director.
Wow.
And then he had sex with a 13 year old and I had to go to France and he can
never come back
I think.
Yeah.
It didn't he drug or something to,
uh,
she was on drugs and she was high and he sodomized her as well in the Jacuzzi.
Did he drug her?
Did he know?
I think she was doing the drugs and she had had sex with somebody else and she'd
been there before,
but she's 13.
I had an argument with a bunch of fans of his and I said,
look,
it's fine.
I know that you're coming up with reasons why he could and he should be let back
in United States is fine.
If it was your daughter,
if it was your 13 year old,
13 just just how would you feel?
That's not the point.
It is the point.
Oh,
how's that?
Not The point.
The point is like,
well,
the only thing that could be not the point is,
is he that same guy now?
Is He that same guy now or were you dealing with a guy who,
if many people don't know,
Roman Polanski terrible as he might be,
was suffered one of the most insane things that can ever happen to him.
But the Holocaust,
the Manson family killed his wife and cut his pregnant wife's belly open.
Yeah,
and smeared blood all over the wall.
I mean,
what would they did?
That was the Tate labianca murders.
Sharon Tate was Roman Polanski's wife access,
right.
It was his baby at the time.
And his wife at the time.
I mean that has got to be a mind breaker.
Now I'm not saying that that would resort someone to pedophilia,
but I mean who knows what was going on in that guy's mind or life at that point.
If he's not that guy anymore and that woman wherever she is,
if she's still alive,
forgives him.
I could see him being able to lead a normal life.
I mean there's been enough.
He was also,
I believe a concentration camp survivor,
or at least he had been in the Holocaust and Poland as a Jew and had to flee.
Yeah.
I think one of those too,
I remember as well.
So it's like,
look,
that guy's been through some horrific,
horrific shit and it's certainly doesn't justify or exonerate him rather from
anything terrible that he's done.
But at a certain point in time you've got to go like,
what should be,
what should be done about something that happened 25 years ago?
Should you have to do time in jail?
Has He escaped there as the statute of limitations for that very reason that to
answer that question and,
and the other one or the other.
Do you know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
Well that's why the statue of limitations exist because you are not thought to
be that person anymore.
I believe that's the,
the logic behind,
I believe that's at least the partial logic behind that law wasn't that one of
the crazy things about like contracts like contracts and leases and things along
those lines.
Like it's like a greeting
that you're going to be the same person to a certain extent,
like a marriage or death row committed a crime and he was 18 and now he's 45 and
is a very different person than I was when he was 18.
Uh,
that was,
um,
there are a lot of examples of that.
Well,
it's why are you expected to be responsible for things that you did 18 over but
under 18 you become a juvenile and you have like different,
it's physiological.
Actually the reason for that is that the frontal cortex of a teenager is not
fully developed,
and that's the area of your brand new use to make decisions.
And so teenagers,
biologically t from,
from what I understand,
it's more impulsive and all that.
Especially boys.
Teenage boys have the worst of that.
And they say until they're 25 like it doesn't even fully form.
Like that's why they said that if you want to get rid of all crimes,
just take all 14 year old boys,
take them 14 in the age of 21 put black men in prison jail,
never having a violent crime.
Well,
they had a,
they had a study about the amount of violent crimes that are committed by people
in that age range and it's overwhelming.
Yeah.
And did a lot of it is just,
you know,
it was a lack of perspective,
lack of understanding what the consequences of your actions are and these weird
impulses that teenagers have,
these weird ancient fucking primate impulses that still exist that are,
you know,
I remember them very well.
I just got over him two or three years ago.
Yeah,
man,
it's,
um,
it's not easy evolving.
The other thing,
I mean,
I don't know whether he knew she was 13.
There are a lot of issues,
but I mean,
at the end of the day,
if you have sex with a 13 year old,
you know,
and she's drugged up.
I Dunno man,
you know?
Yeah.
I can't,
I can't forgive you.
No,
it's a hundred percent crazy.
Yeah.
The other two factors though,
the Holocaust thing and the,
um,
whether or not that's true.
Is that true?
Do we figure that out?
I think he had to flee the code.
He was living in a crack out ghettos.
He wasn't in like a,
not a crack.
I'll get us,
but let me give an example.
The crack.
I'll get us.
I believe this is a good statistic.
Uh,
4 million Jews live there roughly over almost 700 years,
uh,
in,
in Poland.
They were a huge part of the fabric,
the academic fabric and the business fabric.
And by the end of that,
four years,
five years of 4 million,
5 million Jews,
there were about less than 50,000 left.
They'd all been killed and crack.
I remember most of the,
the terrible concentration camps were in Poland.
And if you lived in that Krakow ghetto during that time period,
it was the worst.
Some of the worst.
It's probably one of the worst places to be in the history of the look of that.
During the age of five,
he attended primary school for only a few weeks until all the Jewish children
were abrupt,
spelled yup.
God,
that's gotta be so fucking scary.
You'll just tell your children who can't go to school anymore because you're
Jews.
And they got,
and they were sent off,
sent off to concentration camps,
killed very quickly.
A lot of them died on the trains,
on those children over the age of 12 to wear white arm bands with the Blue Star
of David imprinted for visual identification.
Fuck.
Oh.
And again,
this doesn't exist.
His father taken away.
This is horrible,
horrible,
horrible shit.
Yeah,
yeah.
But it's still like,
okay,
so what do you do with a guy like that?
What do you do?
Do you let him back in here?
I mean he obviously went through a bunch of horrendous shit.
Do you make them come back in here and go to jail?
Like what do you do?
Like you say,
Hey,
you can come back and live in America but you have to go to jail for a year.
How long,
how many years you make them go to jail for what he did?
Um,
I don't know.
I can't answer your question.
I just want in five years,
like what you know today it would say it would be 25 years at least.
Right?
If someone did that to a 13 year old,
you'd say 25 years in jail.
Um,
if,
if he comes over here and it's so many years after the crime,
does he have to do the same amount of time that he would have had to do if it
was the 1970s when he was convicted?
I don't think that it came over here.
I don't think if he came over here and now he would,
he would be thrown in jail.
Woody.
But which my part questions would you be subject to the ideas and the laws of
1970 oh,
that's interesting.
What would you be subject to the ideas and the laws of 2015 you were tried in
absentia then you would be,
hmm.
But I'm not sure.
Yeah,
because I think the,
the probably the punishments probably varied between then and now the way,
well,
the punishments also vary on circumstance.
So rape,
murder have a specific,
you know,
they carry with them a penalty.
That penalty is predicated upon the circumstances and a lot of other things.
But that wasn't always the case.
Was it a that well there's dead now you're talking about the difference in
natural law and,
and you know,
circumstantial law.
So you know,
the natural law would say whatever the case,
what you did was out of the,
out of the nature of how human beings are baby,
you stole something.
There's no other reason.
There's no other circumstance.
It doesn't matter.
It's not relevant.
You go to jail,
you killed somebody.
The fact of the matter is that it's unnatural kill somebody.
You,
you,
you pay with your life.
Modern societies realize that crimes are committed.
Um,
and I don't even think was modern societies.
I mean,
there was always the question.
they're the biggest CICERO,
he goes back to the Romans where it says,
look,
if you park your chariot here,
uh,
in this town,
well you're,
you're going to get a fine.
Oh,
but you know what,
where I live in Carthage,
I can park my chariot there.
And the guy goes,
right,
well here's a,
here's a morning.
Don't do it again because now you're in Rome.
But if you snatch a baby out of a woman's arms and kill it or something
terrible,
regardless,
the law will say in Rome,
no,
you go to jail.
Nobody in Carthage,
we're allowed to do that.
Or I'm from the Mongol talked our steps.
We do that.
Fine.
That's fine.
You're still gonna pay with your why,
because what you did falls under an unnatural act.
So no matter what your culture says,
that was an unnatural act and unnatural acts which would meaning they were
outside the realm of human conduct.
And so you must pay a price regardless of where you're from,
including whether or not you knew that was right or wrong.
That's a very important aspect of law.
It's something that you know,
that people talk about all the time.
That's how you start drawing distinctions between crimes that are,
um,
excusable based on circumstance and crimes that just like drugs or how about
drug smuggling is one thing,
but there are crimes like all of us in most societies would suggest that if an
adult has sex with a five year old,
I don't give a fuck.
So natural.
It's not unnatural crime.
And you're,
you're gonna do,
you're going to do your juicy
growed creator got life in prison without the possibility of parole.
No.
Did you see that?
It's insane.
The Silk Road has in itself kind of stuff?
No,
the Silk Road was a dark web.
Uh,
there's a great,
um,
a documentary by Alex Winter,
what's it called?
The deep web.
And it's about the dark web.
It's about this,
this system that was created by the military and they were using it to buy and
sell drugs.
And some people who bought those drugs died and they,
they overdosed these people that were using it.
We're not him.
It wasn't the guy who created it.
The guy created just a portal for people to use it.
He created a way for people to communicate and exchange drugs for money or for
bitcoins or for whatever they were investigated by the DEA agents,
turned out the DEA and stole like hundreds of thousands of dollars in bitcoin
and transferred it into personal accounts and there was a lot of fuckery
involved and he went to jail and they just tried him and convicted him and the
judge sentenced him to life in prison life for creating a website that appeals
not successful.
He will concurrently serve two life sentences,
a 20 year sentence,
a 15 year old sentence,
15 year sentence and a five year sentence without parole.
Wow.
Fuck man.
For creating this technology,
this sort of a secret tunnel to,
well he,
he,
he created a way for people to be able to buy and sell drugs,
illegal drugs.
Was he working for a cartel or something or no?
No.
He was working.
He thought he was working for good because he's talented programmer and he
figured out a way to let people buy things that they wanted to buy.
It was giving people the opportunity away to anonymously or semi anonymously
trade goods and funds for things that were deemed prohibited from some guys that
they weren't able to argue create a better defense for him.
Well,
I don't think you get a chance to,
man.
I think you'd get railroaded by the government in these sort of cases.
They wanted to convict him.
You know,
they,
if they want to,
they can keep things out of evidence.
Like the idea that you get a totally fair trial is really sad.
It's,
it's not the case,
especially when it comes to drugs.
You know,
when Tom Mccormick got arrested and he went to jail for growing medical
marijuana legally under state laws,
the addressed him,
they arrested him and prosecuted him in a federal court.
When they get you in a federal court,
the first thing they tell you is there is no such thing as medical marijuana.
So you're not allowed to mention medical marijuana.
You can't use it as defense.
You can't bring it up like you could cause a mistrial or you could get
sanctioned by the court.
If you change the definitions,
if you bring up the fact that it's legal in your state,
so this is not legal federally,
it's irrelevant.
So they silence you from communicating the realities of this nuance situation.
They try to pretend that it's black and white.
You were selling drugs,
yes or no?
Well,
yes,
but I was selling the legally in the state of California as voted upon by the
people of California.
There was a proposition that was passed.
Medical marijuana was passed.
I was selling it legally through this proposition.
And you,
they can't say that.
So he went to jail because he never in his defense that he ever was he ever
allowed to even say he was growing it legally in his state because federal
charges,
Trump state law,
federal government just decides their dictators.
They just decide,
I don't give a fuck what you voted for.
The whole group of us,
we say,
fuck you.
And we say,
fuck you about something that's never killed a single person ever.
Amazing.
We were were were talking about all these different things that kill people were
talking about salt killing people and aspirin killing people and how many people
die from drinking too much water?
Even though millions of people smoke weed,
no one dies from it.
You just can't do it.
You can't do it.
You could die from water way quicker than you could die from.
Weird God.
Damn.
It's stupid as fuck.
And the fact that people will go to jail for that and have gone to jail for that
is stupid as fuck.
It's a mantra.
It's changing.
It's another thing.
I think the evidence is just too overwhelming.
It is.
It's an old law,
but it's amazing how,
how slowly these things move when it comes to,
to getting rid of a law get,
because there's a kind of the up around enforcing that law.
Exactly,
and there's a lot of money in enforcing lobbyists when it comes to prison guard
groups that want to keep their jobs privatized prisons.
There's a lot of that.
It's a lot of really with the flat tax and well why not just tax people a
certain percentage just make a flat tax and no big deal.
There are just too many vested interests in,
you know the,
how the tax code is so complicated.
You got to hire accountants and you've got to hire a lot of people that help you
with that stuff.
I mean,
so do you think that's why people don't want a flat tire?
It's one of the
reasons the pressure,
the pressure is on conspiracy.
It's just it people who have an incentive to keep the system the way it is.
Well it's also the fact that we were talking about before where you don't have
to,
they don't have to account for all the money that you give them.
That seems insane.
Like could you imagine a new system if they tried to start it off with fresh
today we just want,
you know,
x amount of money and a don't worry about it.
We're just going to run everything.
But you should show me where my money went.
Show everybody where their money,
man.
No,
it's all compare notes.
Yeah.
Find out how much money is being spent on shit that we don't want.
All right?
You don't get it.
Say,
well right now I don't know what I'm taxed,
but I probably see half of my money.
Just think about you work for the government.
I was going to say 50% of my day is spent working for someone else.
You sort of government,
you spend a lot of money.
That money gets taxed on everything you buy gets taxed.
And on top of that,
the money itself gets taxed.
Yeah,
that's right.
So how much,
how much they really need [inaudible] how are you feeling?
What are they doing with it?
Passing laws and forcing those laws and taxing.
It takes a lot to run a coercive,
a body called the u s federal government.
Um,
you need that almost libertarian beliefs.
The libertarian believes that government should be treated like a necessary
evil.
A,
you need it for some things.
That's it.
That's the motto.
But you,
you,
you should treat it as though it's a necessary evil.
Be will be aware that government always does two things.
It always grows and it's nature is coercive and,
and I'm going to quote my father is not my idea,
but he always says government is in business of intent not results.
There is an intention.
There's an intention.
I'm going to pass a healthcare law.
Uh,
it's going to be 2,400 pages.
Nobody will read it.
No one who voted into law.
They're not going to read it.
It's just too complicated.
But it will be 2,400 pages and actually more than that at the end of it.
Um,
and it's intended to make healthcare more affordable for everybody who wouldn't
want that.
I do.
It's like the Patriot Act.
It's the intention.
Now let's see how it works in practice.
That's what you have to be aware of.
It's not very effective.
And more importantly,
we should all know that it's not the only answer.
There are other ways to engineer what we call equality of opportunity.
There are other ways.
You just have to be a little more creative than to say,
let's tack people tax the rich quote unquote,
what?
By the way,
the rich and the poor,
it's always changing.
Isn't it?
Isn't it always moving?
Some people start out in bad jobs,
they worked their way up.
Make a lot of money.
You got to just be careful with when you talk about this stuff,
it's a changing definition and we are stuck in orthodoxy of thinking.
Well it's a break in the camps.
It was established a long fucking time ago when the world was different,
the world was way different when they started establishing income tax.
It was just way different and we can just,
they could get away with dictator type shit like that.
But if there was no tax system in place and they just started taxing us,
taking all this money,
we were like,
well Whoa,
whoa,
Whoa,
whoa.
What the fuck man?
Like if you were just paying state taxes,
I think we should be paying income tax,
sales tax,
but there's a way to make taxes really fair.
Like I think there's,
I should be a carbon tax.
And what I mean by that,
I said you spend a lot of money on,
if you put a lot of carbon in the air,
then just pay your share that so,
so in other words,
if you have a really big,
you want to buy a big truck with lots of power,
that's fine,
but it's going to cost you a little more money.
Your where you,
whatever,
whatever carbon you use,
depending on how much we'll kind of fossil fuel use can to put out a certain
metric of,
of carbon in the air,
you could tax it that way.
You don't have to accept that.
Makes Sense.
It also makes sense,
the idea that if you buy something like say if you buy a new car,
you're going to use the roads.
Like you should like the,
you're benefiting from some other work that had to be done and I had to be paid
for.
So for every percentage of every car they should be something that goes to some
highway fund.
I think there is,
by the way.
That makes sense.
Yeah,
that totally makes sense.
Yeah.
I think a lot of taxes makes sense.
What doesn't make sense is that we don't get an accounting of it and that it's
totally,
I mean the budget and the,
when you find out what the deficit is,
you're like,
wait a minute,
what are you talking about?
How would that even mean?
Trillions of you owe trillions to fucking hoo.
Let,
let me ask you this question.
So when you,
you're paying for social security,
whether you know it or not,
you're paying,
you're paying so security.
So when you retire at 65 you'll be eligible to a check every month or we can get
that even if you're rich.
Now let me ask you this.
You do well you do good question,
but more importantly that's crazy.
You're going to get it when it starts at 65 right?
It's the people's bank.
What happens when you die at 64 what happens to that money?
What happens exactly?
Guess what?
What family doesn't get it?
Well that's what I understand.
It goes into the ether so someone steals it.
Where does your,
where does your self security go when you die?
Back into the till.
It's what I believe.
And then what happens there?
Um,
I don't know if you've been paying into a til for a long time.
Well,
you have to look no further than civil forfeiture laws.
Look at those fucking creepy things where they just pull you over and you have
10,000 bucks on you and they decide we're going to take it because we think
you're selling drugs and you think those are by on my way to buy a fucking car.
They could take your money and then you've got to fight for it and Cora,
while you're going to have to prove it big guy and they'll take your fucking
money and spend it on shit for the,
it's the biggest thing.
It's the biggest thing you have to watch out for.
It's kind of got busted.
They bought a Margarita machine with the money that they stole from someone that
I surprise.
What a surprise.
The growth of the state and what you mean by growth is state.
It's just more people or people,
people who are in a position of power over you.
And when they have something written down,
they think they're allowed to enforce it because it's written down.
It's a law look.
It's written right there.
Yeah.
Even if it doesn't make any sense.
And then you have to,
don't forget if you have a law and then you have people that enforce the law,
you must also have watchdogs,
you have to have an agency that actually watches those people just like the cops
having turned on the Ferris.
But who watches the watchers?
So,
so,
so the biggest question in political philosophy is what the biggest question and
political philosophy is.
Who is governing the governor?
Yeah.
I'm so fucking profound.
Not really.
Hey Jamie,
can you look up that social security statistic,
which is where's the money go.
Thank you.
We're going to have to wrap this pitch up.
What time is it?
Four 17 Irvine tonight before I forget.
And Big Brown would kick my ass if she should go ahead.
Our shirts are dropping Monday at 7:00 PM.
We've got these new awesome shirts that I wish I said I had a hand in designing,
but big brown did.
And uh,
there,
there are some of our best shots yet seven o'clock,
Monday,
7:00 PM they're dropping foster kitties.
Here's the reality.
If you should die before you begin to get your monthly check,
your family will get a payment in cash amounting to 3.5 cents on every dollar of
wages you have earned after 1936.
If for example,
you should die at age 64 and you had earned $25 a week for 10 years before that
time,
your family would receive $455.
That's not much.
I think that's trying to say.
On the other hand,
it says on tile other hand.
if you have not worked enough to get the regular monthly checks,
by the time you're 65,
you will get a lump sum.
Or if you should die,
your family or a state would get a lumps on.
So you want to get one 3.5 cents on every dollar of wage Jews that you earned,
they get $3.50 cents on every dollar of wages that you earned after 1930.
So is that 3.5% 3.5 cents on every dollar.
That would be three blank.
This is also from 1936 oh Jesus could have also changed since then.
So security,
we shouldn't read anything for those people thought the world was flat.
I think it might be different now.
It might be different.
There's not a lot on this country will give it is the social security,
the idea of who knows how much it's changed.
But the idea behind it is great.
You know the idea that you're going to throw some money in and that it's going
to help old people out when they can't work anymore.
It sounds wonderful.
But they live in abject poverty,
you know,
and pay much.
Gotta pay so little.
I know.
And it's,
how else could you do it?
I mean,
is there enough money out there to pay everybody?
Well,
I get,
I got a sag pension.
I'll get some real money for my sag pension.
We could shoot an act demand screen actors guild,
Bro.
Sexy Bitch.
All that time and acting class paid off kids.
But Ryan motherfucking kaolin with a y.
Why you got to tonight?
I gotta go have the traffic to Irvine is a mother fucker.
Yes you do.
I had a great time there last night.
A bunch of crazy trucks,
birthday parties and Shit Day.
Oh,
come see me.
Come see me in San Francisco.
See You fucks punchline June 25th 26th 27th go my fries at 26 27 28 I don't
know,
man.
Something,
something wacky alongside San Francisco.
Gerald la in San Francisco.
June.
One of the best clubs in the country,
by the way.
Love it.
Could designed
Grad a great vibe to it.
Yep.
All right,
your fucks.
We'll see a much love,
very professionally kisses Multnomah.
Oh,
sure.